Social media is changing our minds.
Social media acts like a drug.
My guest today is Max Fisher.
Max is a writer for the New York Times,
and he's the author of a brand new vitally important book
called The Chaos Machine.
80% Of Americans are taking a drug 15 times a day
without realizing it's a drug.
It's a referendum on all of the damage
currently being wrought by social media.
Social media has much more power
to affect how you think and how you feel
than you might believe.
I've become increasingly convinced
that the impact of social media and technology on our lives
and the lives of our children
is truly one of the great existential issues of our time.
Just spending time on it,
you inevitably end up not just serving the platform
when you're online, but in your offline life,
your emotional balance changes.
I'm very excited to share with you
what I think is a very important conversation.
So please hit that Subscribe button.
And with that, I give you Max Fisher.
(dramatic music)
Cool, so excited to have you here today
to talk about super important matters.
So I applaud you for writing this book.
It really is like the most comprehensive accounting
of what's going on like from this forensic perspective
of how the internet is warping our minds,
driving us apart from each other,
increasing radicalization and the like.
And so I guess the first question I have for you is,
it's an interesting subject matter for you to tackle
because you're not a tech reporter,
you're like a foreign affairs reporter.
You know, international affairs, et cetera.
So talk a little bit about, you know,
what brought you into this world
and why it captured you so to,
you know, spend years writing, putting this book together.
It wasn't something that I initially,
I will be honest, took seriously.
I thought of social media as kind of this thing
that was off to the side.
I know that after 2016,
there was this kind of question out there about,
did social media have something to do
with the Trump phenomenon with the election?
And I, maybe like a lot of people, somewhat naively thought,
well, maybe it's kind of a neutral amplifier
for things that are already out there.
Maybe it exaggerates certain tendencies a little bit,
but it's just the internet, it's just a website.
How influential could it possibly be?
And it started to change for me
about a year after Trump's election
when I was in me in Myanmar to report on the genocide there,
which was this really horrible
and very sudden explosion of violence
between the country's ethnic majority
and an ethnic minority that partly was led by the state.
But a lot of it was also ground up and spontaneous.
And being there on the ground,
I was far from the only person to notice
that social media seemed to be playing
some kind of a huge role in what was happening.
In every conversation you would have with someone,
whatever side they were on,
they would always bring it back to social media.
And even the United Nations,
which it still blows my mind that United Nations said this.
One of their top officials later said
that Facebook had played a determining role in the genocide.
Not just in hosting hate speech,
not just in being a platform
that extremists have manipulated,
but in actually driving it by what their systems promoted,
and in how effective they were at inculcating
so many people in that country into this point of view.
And that started to really get my mind going
because it felt, in a lot of ways,
somewhat similar to what had happened in the United States,
this kind of like social upheaval
that seemed to be linked back to this technology.
And because shortly after that,
I started noticing that pretty much everywhere I went
as a reporter for the Times, you know,
traveling around to different parts of the world,
I would hear really similar stories to the Trump phenomenon,
or to Myanmar that always seemed to link back
to social media.
And it would be smaller in scale,
it would be a village that had erupted into violence.
It would be a far right figure who had suddenly jumped
from the fringes,
to completely dominating their local society
based on social media.
And that was when I started to think,
this is more than just a bunch of websites.
It's more than just a bunch of apps,
it's tapping into and it's changing something
really powerful.
And these big instances that we're seeing
are probably just the tip of the iceberg,
because if it's something whose effects
are being cycled through all of us
at this very individual granular level,
then these changes are probably way deeper
than we appreciate.
And that became this four or five year quest
to try to understand
as rigorously and empirically as I could
what that actual effect is.
Was Myanmar the first international flashpoint for this?
I mean it sort of belies the idealistic promise
of social media is born out by Arab Spring, right?
It's like a mirror, you know, reflection of that,
the opposite of it.
But there is this sense
or sort of a prevailing conventional wisdom
that this is predominantly an American problem, right?
Like just last week, the other day,
Mark Zuckerberg on Joe Rogan's podcast,
he was asked about polarization,
and his response was that it,
there was something uniquely American about it.
And your book is this global adventure
where you basically put that lie to the test.
And it's very clear that this is,
although it's, you know, manifesting,
metastasizing in the United States,
it's an international problem.
Like you're in Germany, you're in Austria,
you're in Myanmar, you're in Sri Lanka,
like all of these places where you're seeing
incidents of animosity, and violence, and polarization
that can directly be tracked back to the algorithmic power
of these, you know, mega social media platforms
and how that's driving behavior.
You really did read the book.
I did, yeah.
Most of it.
I told you, I'm about halfway through it.
I don't, well it's very flattering to hear it,
hear that it resonated.
So to my great shame, there were actually instances
that I covered well before 2016,
that in retrospect were exactly what you're saying,
where these very similar patterns of polarization
and turning society against itself.
There was this case in 2013 in India,
so 100 years ago basically,
that looked a lot like the Trump phenomenon
and Myanmar combined,
where it was rumors that started
with a couple of very small accounts on Facebook
about Muslims and Hindus,
potentially threatening each other
in one very remote part of the country.
And the system, even that far back
when it was much more rudimentary
and much less powerful than it is now,
identified that rumor as something
that was gonna really drive engagement,
and it was really going to excite users,
and not just glue them to the platform,
but get them to share the rumor
and to get people, more people clicking.
And so it pushed that out to huge parts of the country.
And within a couple of weeks,
that this cycle that is now very familiar
of misinformation, leading to hate speech,
leading to incitement,
every step of it being promoted very assiduously
by the platform,
led to this explosion of violence,
and I think tens of thousands of people
pushed out of their homes,
which if that had happened now,
we would very readily identify this was something
driven by social media,
but it was a time, like you said,
just after the Arab Spring,
when we still thought of social media
as something that was going to bring freedom and revolution.
And the Obama administration actually stepped in
to tell the Indian government
which had blocked a bunch of the websites,
that you need to unblock them
because we believe in freedom and freedom of speech,
which is a perfectly reasonable position 10 years ago,
but now we would maybe look at a little bit differently.
So maybe Mark Zuckerberg believes that polarization
is something that is just happening in America,
and what could his platform possibly have to do with it?
But he has been presented,
including by Facebook's own researchers
with reams and reams of evidence,
that its systems are not neutral
and that it drives this behavior.
Sure.
I mean the book opens with this whistleblower
that you name Jacob,
who becomes kind of a harbinger of,
you know, what's to unfold
in terms of the scale of the problem
and the degree of difficulty in tackling it.
So talk a little bit about that.
I mean that seems to also be, you know, some,
you rooted this guy out
and he becomes kind of a bit of a slight protagonist
in terms of how you tell the story.
He actually found me,
and he, like a lot of people in the book
who are the whistleblowers,
whether they're in Silicon Valley, outside of it,
the people who study the platforms,
he was someone who started as a true believer.
He lives in a country where,
I'm trying to think about how much I can say
about where he lives,
'cause I don't want him to get, you know, identified,
where it was very important to him
that social media was there
to bring the freedom and democracy
that people in Silicon Valley were promising.
And he really believed in that.
His job was to click through posts on the platform to say,
this breaks the rules, this doesn't break the rules,
that Facebook and the other platforms
employ thousands of these peoples
to basically moderate and kind of manage the platforms.
And he was really worried,
because he saw that the hate and the lies
and the misinformation
seemed to be getting worse and worse all the time.
And he had a fuzzy sense in the way that a lot of us did,
but not proof that the system itself was driving it.
And he also had this giant stack of documents
that were Facebook's internal rule books
for how to govern the platform.
And he passed those on to me because he said,
these are, they're nonsense, they're gibberish.
A lot of them don't make sense, they don't fit together,
there are mistakes in them.
And it's not that the rules are nefarious.
When I wrote a story for the Times on them,
I think there were a lot of people looking for,
well, they're, you know, trying to control free speech
and trying to control politics.
I think they're not,
they're really just trying to tamp down,
I mean, PR crises in a lot of cases,
some of the documents say explicitly is the goal.
But the attention and care in given to them
was at an alarmingly low level,
and so that was why he wanted me to broadcast them out
so that the people in the company who he thought
and really believed wanted to do the right thing
would come in and save the day and fix them.
Right, and so that was that article that you wrote in 2018
for the Times, right, where you kind of exposed all of this,
these manuals that are, you know,
almost impossible to consume, let alone memorize,
that are often contradictory in terms of their rules
about how to police this stuff.
And then you have these moderators who are working
in sort of boiler room situations,
having to make snap decisions in mere seconds
based on posts, like it's an impossible task.
This is not the way that you're gonna be able to combat
these problems.
Eight seconds a post was what he had to do.
And not only can you not combat the problems,
but they're janitors trying to clean up this mess
that Facebook is making faster
than they can possibly clean up.
They're kind of like air fresheners
outside of a giant factory waste disposal dump.
You know, they could have more and more moderators
and better rule books,
but the problem was still
what was coming out of the platforms.
Right, so maybe steel man your case for the problem.
Like what is the problem?
Oh man, what is the problem?
I mean, in some level I think the most sympathetic case
that you can make for the platform,
is that on some level, the problem is human nature.
An enormous amount of the book
ended up being focused on something
I did not think it was going to be focused on,
which are the frailties in our nature basically.
And some of those are things that evolved in,
some of them are ways that we've constructed society,
that we deal with our own impulses and instincts.
And the basic problem I would say is that
because these social media platforms
are designed over all else to maximize engagement,
which means just whatever they have to do
to get you to spend more time
scrolling, tapping, and sharing
so that they can sell more ads against you,
and so that you will hook in other users
that they can sell ads to,
because of the ruthlessness of their systems,
the scale of their systems,
and the fact that they work by playing on
our most basic social impulses and our social needs
has made them incredibly powerful at bringing out instincts
that we have tried to suppress
in what you would call modernity,
and it bringing out things that we know are harmful for us,
but that are tough to resist when we have this platform
that is giving us a reality
where it feels like it's something that we have to do
or feels like it's something that's necessary
or pleasurable to do.
Right, so we have these huge companies
powered by incredibly complex algorithms
that even the people who manage them
don't understand how they work.
Right.
And these are, you know,
driving people towards content rabbit holes, et cetera,
that are forming opinions
and often translating into behaviors
in the real world, right?
And you analogize this to hell in 2001
where, you know, man has made a machine
that it doesn't quite understand.
Machine destroys man.
And we're in, you know,
some version of that dystopic reality
that's unfolding in real time amongst us.
And I think there is, you know,
there are people like yourself
who are sounding the alarm bell,
but I think there also is this sense,
well, that's the internet.
These are, you know, sort of fringe people.
This isn't what most people think.
Maybe that's true, maybe that isn't,
but you can't deny the real world ramifications
that we're seeing getting played out
through politics and just the decline or the denigration
of public discourse and decorum across the world.
Right, and it's something
that I really wanted to emphasize
in the book is that the kind of extremist,
the you know, QAnon and Stop the Steal,
the extreme edge cases,
that's a really important part of the story,
but I think in some ways the more important part
and the harder to confront part is the subtler,
but still very consequential ways
that it affects those of us
who might think we're separate from that.
Those are those two.
We all think we are.
Right, exactly.
We all think we're immune from that.
Right, we all think that we're right.
We're immune to it, we're smart enough to understand it,
we see it.
Or maybe it affects us a little bit in the sense that,
you know, we know know some habits are not healthy for us,
but we do it anyway.
And I, even someone who went in
having made the decision to write a book
about the harms of social media,
so who could possibly be more overconfident
in their own knowledge of it.
I was shocked to learn about the ways
that it was affecting me as someone
who thinks they were one of the good ones,
and just me specifically, because it really,
how do I put this?
It is something that its influence can be so invisible,
and it's designed to be invisible.
You open up your Instagram or your Twitter,
and you think you're seeing your community.
You think you're seeing your friends or your family,
or you think you're seeing the voices you follow,
the people you wanna hear from.
And when you interact with them,
the feedback that you get in terms of what travels,
what gets likes, what doesn't get likes,
you think that that is feedback from real people.
But these are overwhelmingly the choices
of these automated systems
that are deciding what's gonna get attention,
what's not gonna get attention,
because the amount of content
that's on social media is huge,
and the amount of content you can see is tiny.
So we can tell almost any story at once by what it pulls out
and what presents to you and how it presents it to you.
And it smuggles its choices through your community
in a way that feels neutral, but is not,
and in a way that has much more power
to affect how you think and how you feel
than you might believe,
because we derive so much of our emotional state
and so much of our sense
of how to behave and even what we think we want internally
or how we feel internally from the cues
that we take from people around us
that we think are from the people around us.
Right, and that's a big piece in the book,
like our group identity and--
Exactly, yeah.
You know, how we kind of gauge status
amongst our peers, et cetera.
And when you look at what's being served up to you,
even understanding that that choice is being made
by an algorithm,
and that algorithm is selecting for engagement
with the overriding goal
being the platform maximizing as much time as possible.
And also understanding that what drives engagement
often are things that are at odds with our wellbeing,
things like moral outrage, you know, out group dynamics,
all of these sort of psychological,
you know, kind of buzzwords and keywords
that drive engagement that are definitely understood
by these, you know, equations, correct,
and the people that design them.
But I think it's also important, and your book makes,
you know, a big point of this,
to understand that this is not a reductive situation.
Like we can't just say,
well, we need to change the algorithms,
or we need to change, like this is systemic.
It's baked into the very origin story
of Silicon Valley altogether.
And it was really fascinating as somebody who's,
you know, I used to live in that area,
and I'm familiar with, you know,
many of the people in the places that you describe
in the kind of, you know,
formation of this industry altogether,
and how that makes solving this problem so difficult
because it's bred into the DNA
of how these companies were built from the outset.
So talk a little bit about that.
I think it's super interesting.
So I mean, like we were talking about beforehand,
in some ways it's a story of capitalism,
and I mean, that's when you trace it back at the,
that's in some ways the original sin,
where these companies were built
on this very specific financial model
that turns out to determine basically everything
about how they work and what they do to you.
And that financial model is called,
I mean, of course, you know,
this is called venture capitalism.
And the idea is that someone comes in, an investor,
and they give a kid,
because we're talking about the internet era.
It used to be,
they would give someone who designed a widget
a bunch of money and say,
go build a factory and sell those widgets.
And their, you know, semiconductor, something like that.
So it might be at $10 million,
and it takes 20 years before it turns around
and makes money.
So you have to be really thoughtful
about what your business plan,
how are you gonna bring in revenue with the customers.
That changed at the start of the internet era,
where the way that the model now worked
for venture capitalists
is you wanted to find a kid with a website.
And the reason that you wanted to find a kid with a website
is that you could give them very, very little money,
really, really small investment,
because it's basically free to start a website.
And if they got enough users,
whether or not they made diamond profit,
and some of the biggest success stories in Silicon Valley
never made any profit whatsoever like Netscape,
you could then sell it to a bigger company,
or you could go public,
and then you would have what's called an exit
where your initial investment for $10,000,
now it's worth a million dollars,
or your initial investment for $300,000
is now worth $30 million.
And what this created was this incentive
where if you are an investor looking for the next big hit,
or if you were the, you know,
kid who's trying to start the next big tech company,
what you wanna get is as many users as possible
as quickly as possible
and you do not care about your business model
because that's someone else's problem
after Oracle buys you for half a billion dollars.
And that leads directly to the social media companies,
because their whole thing is owning your attention.
That's the product that they're selling,
because more attention means more users,
which means it's more attractive when you go for that exit.
But the problem is that attention is finite.
There are only so many people in the world
and we only have so many seconds per day.
So it created this arms race for how can,
I mean first it was MySpace,
or these other companies that we've never even heard of now.
And then Facebook and Twitter and YouTube,
how can they compete to get that next second,
that next flick of an eyelid that they can sell ads against.
And as they start putting more and more money into this,
because this is now the entire economy of Silicon Valley
is fighting for your attention,
these systems get more and more sophisticated.
And as you said, even the engineers who are creating them,
because these are automated, AI driven systems,
they don't even know how they're working
or the choices that they're making.
But because they are hiring really, really good people,
because they could pay whatever they want,
they become incredibly powerful and effective
at hooking people in.
Yeah, but even beneath that,
like going another layer deeper into the origin story here,
what's real, you know,
I want to get it like kind of the philosophy
and the psychology.
Oh, you mean like the--
Tracks back all the way to the defense contractors
who fled the East Coast, where they could kind of,
you know, innovate in a way that wasn't possible
given the constraints of the way business was being done
on the Eastern seaboard, created a free spirited,
kind of iconoclastic mentality
that with the advent of the semiconductor chip
and everything that followed,
bred a sort of sensibility of us against them,
and we're rewriting the rule book,
we're creating a revolution of ideas.
We are free of these traditional constraints,
you know, fast forwarding to that famous Apple ad where,
you know, the hammer is being thrown through the screen,
and that Orwellian, you know, kind of thing,
like it's, you know, fuck tradition,
and we're creating, you know,
a new way of being in the world that is liberated,
you know, in the truest sense of that definition
from these traditional ways of being, I guess.
Is that, I don't know if I'm saying that, correct?
No, no, that's exactly right.
Yeah, I misunderstood what you were asking about.
Yeah no, I mean, not what you said is important,
but like I think like that core philosophy
makes solving the problem so difficult
because this, whether you call it libertarianism,
or you know, being an iconoclast,
there's a certain hubris that's kind of stacked into that,
that we know better than you, right,
I guess is the top level way of saying it.
It's a we know better than you that originates in,
like you were saying,
the very first companies in Silicon Valley
which was basically like,
I think it was like peach packing plants,
like not very long ago, like 50, 60 years ago.
And it was this total backwater
that a couple companies moved out to
because they were run by people who were,
for lack of a better word, assholes or cranks.
And they kind of couldn't make it back east.
This was Shockley Semiconductor.
And this sounds like this is this old name,
this must be, you know, 100 years ago, completely removed.
But the thing about the Valley is that it is so small
that just a couple companies that set the culture
in the '50s and '60s,
Shockley Semiconductor and Hewlett Packard,
which are both these companies run by these iconoclast,
where they said, we're gonna empower the engineer
because the suits back east
who were trying to tell us what to do, you know, fuck them.
We know better because we know how to do math
and we're good at math science,
and that's what really matters.
These people set the culture that still rules today
because the people who worked at Shockley and at HP
went on to go found the computer companies basically.
And the people who founded the computer companies
acted as these venture capitalists.
So these are the people who are picking the winners
of the next generation,
designing the company's the next generation, right?
The engineers become the funders.
Exactly, the engineers, and it's very closed.
And it's funny because it's this enormous center of wealth,
but you're dealing with like 100 bold face names
that have selected and guided all the major winners
from that first semiconductor generation,
up through the computers, up through the internet era,
and then up through social media,
and they have been passing on these ideas.
And part of it also comes from the venture capital model,
which says, I'm not gonna find a traditional company,
I'm gonna go find an engineer
who makes a really good widget,
and I'm just gonna give him a ton of money,
and he's gonna know what to do best.
And as an engineer, you internalize that and you say,
well, I'm the best at making widgets,
that means that I should also be in charge
of building the company, designing the products.
And what happens is the products,
which start as just technical stuff,
when you're making semiconductors,
if you have a big ego, that's fine.
What's the danger in that?
The products become the infrastructure
that run the world basically.
With computers first, and then the internet,
and then with social media becomes the infrastructure
that sets our social morals,
and it sets our political norms.
And when you have that engineer mentality,
which still holds that says,
if I, as an engineer,
think that this is the right way to run things,
then who are these other people to tell me?
And it's, what was this line from Mark Zuckerberg?
I think society is a engineering problem.
Exactly right.
Society is a problem that engineering can solve.
Right, right.
And he's said before that I bet there's a math equation
for how we balance the,
or the balance of relationships in our life
and what we care about.
And it's a little scary,
and it's a little scary when you have 23 year old,
24 year old Mark Zuckerberg,
and around the Arab Spring saying we are going to set out
to fundamentally rewire society from the ground up
because we are the smartest ones,
and we're the people to do it.
Right, so you have that sort of engineering mentality,
and that at some point,
that intersects with social psychology, right?
And so much of this can be tracked back to BJ Fogg's class
at what's the lab call that he--
Persuasion one, yeah.
So all of these students, Tristan Harris being among them,
Kevin Systrom, founder of Instagram,
like a lot of people took his class
that went on to found these companies,
and he was really, you know, steeped in this,
in this social science of how to drive engagement,
and you know, how the human mind operates to,
you know, kind of, you know, create products and tools
that will, you know, basically addict people.
It's so crazy to read the transcripts of conferences
from like 10 years ago,
which is kind of the peak of this era
of like the persuasion lab,
and this guy who wrote this book,
I think it was called Persuasion,
that was basically explaining how to implement these ideas.
How open a lot of these consultants in the Valley were,
and a lot of the CEOs in the Valley were about,
we wanna design products
that are going to be deliberately addictive.
And not just addictive in the sense
that it's like a game and it'll be fun to use,
but chemically addictive,
and that we are going to exploit dopamine,
and that we are going to model our products on casinos
and on slot machines.
And that's why your phone,
it looks like a slot machine very deliberately,
where it has these little buttons and these widgets.
And it makes the little like vibration haptic feedback
when you use it.
And that is designed like your Pavlov's dog,
to train you to associate certain feedback
with using your phone.
And there's one case from one of these lectures that was,
you know, they would never say this now
because they know how bad it sounds,
but the 10 years ago in the Valley it was very common
where this consultant who is teaching companies
how to do persuasion,
which means getting your customers to change their behavior.
Sounds a little scarier when you define it.
This example that he used was that Facebook
creates a sensation when you go onto it,
he uses this hypothetical when Barbara,
Barbara goes onto Facebook,
because she wants to connect with her friends and family.
And Facebook creates a simulation of that,
that actually feels like it is really exaggerated in scale.
And it feels like a much more extreme version
of that connection.
Because when you connect with someone in the real world,
you have, you know,
when you chat with people in the real world,
you're dealing with maybe five people at once.
And the feedback that you'll get will be kind of implicit.
When you go onto social media, if you post something,
you might get positive feedback from 20 people,
or 100 people, or 1,000 people.
So it chases this desire for human connection,
then serves you an exaggerated version of it.
And it serves it to you at this incredible convenience
so that when you want that feeling,
you'll pick up your phone instead of going to find a person.
But the thing about this that's really pernicious,
is that it doesn't actually deliver
that feeling of connection.
And this consultant was very open about this.
He said that what it gives you is a dopamine boost,
that you get that initially makes you think
that you were satisfying the social urge
to connect with other people,
but in fact, because it does not fulfill it,
you will continue to be lonely and crave that,
so you will go back to Facebook more and more.
And then over time, Barbara, this woman who we invented,
will learn to pick up her phone
and to really chase this feeling of connection
through her phone that she will never get by design
so that she'll keep picking it up more and more,
which I think I don't resonated with me when I heard that.
Yeah, I mean that is dark, right?
It is, yeah.
It's like so dark.
It really is.
I mean you're essentially setting up a digital environment
that is equivalent to chasing the dragon.
Like you're trying to get hot.
You're never gonna quite get that high,
but it's luring you back time and time again.
I really think that if there's one thing
I want people to take away from this book,
it's not about the political ramifications,
it's not about regulation with tech companies.
All that stuff is really important,
but I would just really like for people to take away
that social media acts like a drug,
and to think of it like a drug.
And I think when you start to see
that this is something that doesn't just deliberately,
deliberately by design, addict you like a drug,
but that it also changes your behavior,
and it changes the way that your mind works akin to a drug,
it makes it much easier to understand
because it's a drug that hides itself
because you don't realize that that's what it's doing.
You think you're just going on
and you're talking to your friends, but you're actually not,
you're interfacing with this technology.
And it's also a very pernicious drug
because whereas, say alcohol will play on
or distort your mood, your sense of balance,
it's mostly a hormonal physical response.
Social media plays through social impulses
that where you're not used to thinking of
as affected by drugs,
but it is something that absolutely changes that,
and it is a drug that each of us takes,
I think the average is like 15 times a day every single day.
I think American life makes a little bit more sense
if you think that 80% of Americans are taking a drug
15 times a day without realizing it's a drug,
that some things start to kind of click into place.
Yeah.
And I think that if you see it that way as a consumer,
trying to navigate life that is,
you know, dominated by social media,
it becomes a little easier to understand
what's the difference between what's coming from me,
and things that I actually want,
or emotions or urges that I'm actually feeling,
and what's being instilled in me by this drug
that's delivered to me by the largest companies
in human history?
Sure, and it goes back to that point you made earlier
about how we all think that we're independent minded,
and we're not, you know,
prone to being impulsed in that way.
Like I'm strong enough.
I'm of sound mind and body.
I can resist this, or I'm not gonna get lured down
some crazy rabbit hole
because I'm sentient, and independent, and thought
and all of the like.
But you know, as movies like The Social Dilemma
did such a good job of showing,
you know, we are powerless
against the amount of science and technology
that's gone into the addictive mechanism here.
So there was two things that you said,
there's the addiction piece, which I think we've explored.
You know, I've had plenty of conversations on this podcast
with people like Johann Hari about that very thing.
I'm more interested in this behavior piece
that you alluded to,
like it is changing our minds.
It's literally changing how we think.
And of course, when you change someone's mind,
it's going to change their behavior.
And so there's tons of interviews that you've done
in this book,
and people that you've spoken to about this very thing.
So maybe like help us understand that,
and flush that out a little bit.
Yeah, let me give you two examples,
one that is kind of small
and one that's a little bit bigger.
There is this very specific type of sentiment
called a moral emotional sentiment.
And that's a complicated way of saying,
any emotion or sentiment that touches
on both an emotional feeling,
and also the moral component means something
that implicates what we think of
as social morals or right and wrong.
So if I said that you were a really kind person,
or I said that you were a liar,
those are moral emotional sentiments.
Another way to think of it is just outrage.
Outrage is the most powerful moral emotional sentiment.
And outrage is different from anger because it means,
I think that you have transgressed
a wrong against the community,
and I think that you've transgressed a wrong
against the social norms that hold us together.
There was this fascinating experiment
that I write about in the book,
where these researchers tried all sorts of different words
on a fake Twitter platform to see what were the words
that were going to increase engagement.
And they basically, every kind of sentiment
was much closer to neutral that they thought.
Angry words didn't seem to have much of an effect,
left leaning or right leaning words, sad words, happy words,
even words like "car wreck",
like exciting words didn't have much of a difference.
But every moral, emotional word had a 20% increase
in the reach of any tweet that contained it, which is huge.
That's nuts.
Although if you have spent time on Twitter,
that's something that you very quickly learn
is that that is the kind of sentiment that travels.
But the piece of this experiment that really stuck with me,
because honestly it hit a little close to home,
is that they would take these research subjects,
and they would try to poll them
and basically gauge their sense of internal outrage.
As a person, how prone to outrage were they
at people who they thought of as their out group?
You know, if they're a Liberal,
people they thought of Conservatives, vice versa,
you know, can be a division by race, by religion.
And people who had a very low propensity to outrage
if the researchers nudge them to say, you know,
send a couple tweets with outraged words in them,
what would happen is that subject would send those tweets,
and they would get a lot of engagement
because that's what the platform does.
It identifies those as engaging,
and pushes them out to a lot of people
and gives you a social reward
in terms of lots of likes and retweets,
is that the subject would internalize that,
and first start to send more tweets like that
just to chase the high.
But then soon enough,
that urge would start to come from within,
the research subject would send outrage tweets
even if they didn't get a reward,
because their nature had fundamentally been changed in the,
what they found in the kind of polls and studies
they would take with these individual people is their,
the outrage they felt internally
even when they were offline had increased.
So this training effect of the platforms
in terms of what works is so powerful,
that just spending time on it,
you inevitably end up not just serving the platform
when you're online, but in your offline life,
your emotional balance changes.
It's really terrifying,
you know, when you think about that.
Yeah.
The fact that something performative
could become so internalized,
that it changes your sensibility and your identity,
and how you think and how you behave
is essentially what you're saying, right?
I can't remember, what was the phrase that was used?
It was something really benign, like, you know,
let the cat chases the dog or something like that.
And then you just, the cat chases the angry dog,
or you would start inserting
like those kind of moral outrage keywords.
The quick brown fox.
And then, you know, engagement,
or how that tweet with traffic,
and it would go way up, right?
Right.
But the fact that somebody could,
from an addictive point of view,
or from a external validation point of view,
start tweeting outrageous stuff for attention,
then over time, start to believe those sentiments.
Right.
And then obviously if you believe those things
are gonna behave differently.
That's what I try to tell,
when I talk to people who spend a lot of time online,
you can always tell, and I used to be one of these people,
that they're a little bit divided between thinking like,
well, I know it's not good for me, but I like being on it,
or I think that there's a lot that's good about it.
The thing that I would tell them is,
look, even if you discount the effect that your tweets have
on other people,
even if you discount the effect
that having these kind of emotional high valence tweets
will have on the public square and broader discourse,
you were training yourself.
You were turning yourself into, you know,
the rat hitting the lever,
and you don't realize it, but you were changing
the way that you think and feel
in order to serve these companies
that already have plenty of money.
(calming music)
We were talking earlier today actually,
kind of about some of the comments that we get,
like when the show reached a certain level of scale,
like you can't escape negative criticism,
like it just part of the deal, right?
But I've noticed the tone and tenor
of the criticism getting darker,
and, you know, it's words like, you know,
"outrageous", or "I'm so disappointed in you",
you know, like you didn't talk about this,
and you talked about that.
Like, I'm sorry, are you really that disappointed?
Like, is this that meaning, you know?
Like the kind of level of negative acrimony
is at a pitch that feels different, new and unique.
But it makes sense, right?
The thing that really stayed with me or struck me
was the story about
Tay, the Microsoft AI trained Twitter bot
and how it, because like this, we're getting into this,
the conversation about radicalization,
like this is how it begins, right?
So I think tell that story,
because I think it really illustrates and underscores
like how this can happen and how quickly it can happen.
This is in a computer example,
but then we can talk about how this happens in human beings.
So this was a chat bot that Microsoft designed
where it was a robot run Twitter account
that would talk to people.
And there'd been a lot of variations on this,
but what was different about this one
is because it was on this platform
that is the largest open forum in human history,
it was absorbing a huge amount of data
in the form of people interacting with it,
and in seeing what engagements did well and what didn't.
And within, I don't remember what it was,
it was like a few days,
like very, very quickly this bot that was just meant to have
friendly conversations with people
had turned into an actual neo-Nazi.
Right, it was literally tweeting out
insane Nazi aphorisms,
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, and some of that was like--
And they had to pull the plug on it.
Like right away, yeah.
And some of that was trolls basically,
who knew how to kind of push the buttons
to get it to see crazy thing.
Right, I mean, was that coming from 4chan then?
Like let's see if we can radicalize this bot
and how quickly we can?
I'm sure, some of that.
And that was the kind of defenses that like look,
some bad actors distorted this thing,
but okay, that's what your algorithm is doing.
That's what the algorithms on these platforms
are just a version of this bot,
except instead of talking to us,
it's determining what are the things
that will win engagement
and then subtly nudging us towards that.
So it was this kind of look behind the curtain, so to speak,
at what these systems are absorbing,
and what's actually out there on the platforms
and the accurate what direction it points in,
it's pretty ugly.
Yeah.
Well in this archeology of radicalization,
you kind of create this timeline of how this,
you know, came to be,
and then, you know, today how pernicious it is,
and I can't help but think back to, you know,
what Kevin Roose did with Rabbit Hole,
and had him on the podcast talking about that.
It feels--
Oh you did, oh nice.
It feels quaint.
I know.
That was during COVID, so we did that virtually.
But, you know, I always riveted by that podcast series,
I encourage, you should be doing this every year.
Like these stories never end,
and it's becoming more and more intense obviously.
But that feels like very quaint now,
compared to like the way that you describe it.
And it feels like this funnel,
it's really a funnel situation that,
you know, begins in places like 4chan and then 8chan,
filters to Reddit, then Reddit filters onto Facebook.
And maybe it bifurcates at that point
between Facebook and YouTube,
and then obviously spills into the real world.
But a real early flashpoint
in the understanding of this radicalization process
begins with Gamergate.
Right.
So Gamergate is something that many of us
have probably forgotten about.
And if we do remember, we probably remember it
as a kind of fringe internet weirdo thing.
But I think it's important to think about,
both because it seeds internet culture as we know it,
and especially the kind of alt-right troll,
Peppe the Frog internet culture.
And also because it becomes the model
for so many patterns that are to follow after that.
And basically how it starts is you have a lot of gamers
are one of the first big, early adopters on social networks,
which is why this happens first with gamers.
It's why Gamergate comes before the alt-right,
it comes before anti-vaxxers, these other things.
And a lot of them are young white guys
who maybe spend a lot of time at home,
maybe feel a little bit lonely,
which is why they play video games or not.
I shouldn't say it's why they play video games.
In some cases, it might be why it is more attractive
as an identity than other forms of identity.
And something that the systems figured out really early on,
and I talked to a guy at YouTube
who worked inside the company on the algorithms
and identified this and tried to, you know,
set off a siren basically to say this is really dangerous.
Something that the systems picked up
is that you could show them gaming videos
and maybe they watch for 10 minutes.
And if you showed them something
that spoke to their sense of identity
and presented it as under siege,
they would watch for much, much longer.
So anything that said gamers under attack.
And that happened to dovetail very effectively
with the sense of,
I don't know if confusion is the right word, anime maybe,
that a lot of young men feel
about just looking for their place in the world,
which is perfectly normal, of course.
But again, what YouTube identified
is that if you are a 13 year old white guy,
something that will really powerfully speak to you
is a sense that your identity is under threat
as a 13 year old white guy.
So what was the villain that these algorithms came up with
was feminists, and you know,
so-called social justice warriors.
And it constructed, partly on YouTube,
partly on 4chan happening somewhat more organically,
but by basically the same mechanisms,
this conspiracy that sounds ridiculous
when you say it out loud,
which is that video game developers
and video game journalists were in league
to suppress the white male spirit
by engineering masculinity out of video games,
and imbuing them with feminist
and LGBT characters and ideas, which is crazy, right?
It's nuts, but these systems are really effective
at gradually nudging people into ideas.
And in fact, that's their favorite way.
That's a key point.
Right.
And it's their favorite way to nudge people
in because if they just show you an extremist video,
maybe you watch for 20 minutes.
But if they show you 10 videos
that gradually bring you up to the idea,
then maybe you're watching for four hours.
And that's all they want.
They just want you watching more, that's it.
So the intent isn't to gradually radicalize you,
the intent is just to keep you on the platform
for as long as possible.
And these algorithms have discovered
that the best way to do that,
is to nudge you in a certain direction.
And as that tap kind of slowly broadens,
that's gonna keep people engaged in the best way.
Right.
People who research extremism, terrorism recruitment,
call that the crisis solution construct.
And the idea is that if you are a recruiter for,
let's say ISIS, you go to someone and you say,
I can see that you are in crisis because you're depressed,
because you don't have a job,
because you're not sure if your place in the world,
that crisis is not actually an individual one.
It's one that afflicts our entire community of,
if it's ISIS, you know, you would say Muslims,
if it's Gamergate, you would say young white male gamers.
It's a collective fight,
but don't worry because I have the solution to your crisis,
which is that we are going to come together
and collectively fight the enemy,
whether it's Christians, feminists,
who, I mean, it doesn't really matter who is.
Right, it's just an in group out group thing.
The aggrieved group,
and then the solution to solving the aggrievement.
Exactly, right.
And it's terrorist recruiters love this
because it is something that radicalizes people into action
by turning this idea of this all consuming struggle
into their entire identity.
And algorithms love it because
that community becomes something that can be super engaging,
because it makes you wanna spend more and more and more time
on the platform, engaging with the ideas,
fighting this battle.
In the case of Gamergate,
the way that it was fought was just a campaign
of horrific harassment against
pretty much every woman involved in the video game industry
or video game journalism.
I interviewed this guy who was,
a kid had a hearing problem, so he had a stutter.
So he spent a lot of time online
because that was the place where he was comfortable
connecting to other people.
But he was on 4chan and Reddit when this was happening.
And he just got swept up,
not because he innately hates women,
or because he's innately a monster,
but because it provided the most supercharged sense
of community and togetherness
that these platforms could possibly deliver.
Purpose.
Purpose, yeah exactly, yeah.
So Gamergate happens,
and everything you need to know about what's happening now
is kind of packed into that story.
But at the time it was sort of considered
a fringe internet thing, like this isn't the real world.
Like yeah, that's interesting that that happened,
but you know, we're all living over here,
and that's more of a curiosity than anything else, right?
And it takes a long time, despite,
you know, many Cassandras, like sounding the alarm bell
saying we should pay attention to this,
because this is only escalating
and there are gonna be bigger
and larger ramifications to this.
It wasn't really given proper consideration at the time.
I didn't, I didn't take it seriously.
And then, you know, even things like Pizzagate
and the inception of QAnon on and all of that, like,
it's just weird, right?
Like well normal people aren't, you know, thinking
that this pizza parlor is, you know,
really secretly a place where human trafficking,
it's just like you'd have to be kind of crazy
to believe that.
So it's easy to dismiss.
But really it is the roots
of any other kind of radicalization funnel
that we're saying, like the principles remain the same.
Right, and the platforms are really good.
And this is not something that people at the companies
are doing consciously,
and identifying those conspiracy or crazy ideas
that are going to be the most engaging,
whether it's Gamergate, whether it's Pizzagate,
and pushing them out to as many people as possible
and creating a larger community around them.
One of the examples that I think about a lot from YouTube,
which is actually quite similar to Gamergate,
but it's a version that I think
it certainly felt much more familiar to me,
is if you, for a long time,
if you search depression on YouTube,
you get a Jordan Peterson video.
And he is someone who will reframe your depression
as part of this larger struggle.
And he doesn't say,
therefore, you should join the alt-right.
That's not, you know, to be fair to him,
he says that it's, you know, social justice warriors,
or feminism are suppressing the masculine spirit.
But YouTube system has learned how to make this connection
that if you were depressed,
or if you are interested in learning about depression,
this is a video that you watch that's very long
because it has this crisis solution construct.
And once it shows you that,
it can then show you a video
that is slightly more alt-right,
and then one that goes further and further right from that.
And it will link them all together
and create this community,
this kind of downward funnel of extremism
that even the people who are making the videos
aren't conscious of, and are not deliberately engendering.
Right, they're just independently making their thing.
But it's one puzzle piece in this larger algorithmic picture
that leads people in a certain one way direction
for the most part, right?
And when I think about this, whether it's,
you know, ISIS, or Incels,
these, you know, the inception point
for almost all of these problems
can be pinpointed to the disenfranchised young male
amidst a culture of, you know,
widening income disparity and lack of opportunity,
and perhaps a dearth of strong, healthy male mentors
or guidance in their lives
who become susceptible to influence,
particularly strong male, sometimes authoritarian influence,
or just strong males who are like, get your shit together,
like make your bed Jordan Peterson style, or whatever it is
who like kind of need that voice in their life, right?
And there are healthy versions of that,
and there are unhealthy versions of that.
And maybe one that's, you know,
slightly bending in a certain direction
is gonna tilt that algorithmic arc
into an unhealthy destination ultimately.
But what is your response to the argument
that this is a mental health problem,
as much as anything else,
like we have to solve the depression situation.
And from an economic perspective,
we have to create more opportunity for these young males
so that they don't end up so vulnerable to these,
you know, information silos,
and get radicalized in that way.
Obviously, you know, it's a huge problem.
It isn't one thing or the other, but you know,
this is what's fueling so much of the problems
that we're seeing kind of metastasize in the real world.
I think that that is absolutely true.
I think that it is absolutely,
it's not something that you can pin entirely on social media
and the vulnerability that people feel
because of a loss of control, a loss of autonomy in society.
I feel like that is something that I see over and over
in the people who get pulled furthest down this rabbit hole.
And that sense of needing a way to feel like
you have some agency in the world is,
it's not a need that social media created.
It's very good at exploiting,
but you're right that as long as that is there,
there's going to be some mechanism,
whether it's a social media algorithm or something else
that finds a way to exploit that
to turn it towards some other nefarious end.
So I think there are,
there are a lot of vulnerabilities
that social media exploits, but does not create.
And in some ways the answer
is to think about those vulnerabilities
and not just the platforms.
Yeah, I mean that has to get addressed in tandem with--
Yeah, absolutely.
With the, you know, the other problem
that we're talking about.
But you know, it is, it's like, it's amazing.
You have vast communities of,
you know, somewhat wayward people who are extremely online
and are looking for connection and belonging, right?
And a lot of these communities,
whether they're on 4chan, or Reddit, or Facebook groups,
or what have you, are serving that purpose,
they're making people connected to other humans
through some sense of shared aggrievement,
or a sense of identity at defining who they are
in opposition to, you know, maybe a more,
you know, traditional in group.
Yeah.
Yes, and something that you hear a lot
when you talk to people who work in deradicalization,
whether it's online or not online,
is that often the answer, even though it sounds pat,
it sounds simplistic,
is just to help someone find
a new sense of community and connection.
And a lot of the stories end with,
you know, oh, he was in an extremist group,
but then he got a girlfriend
And it sounds like like it couldn't possibly be that simple
or it couldn't possibly be that superficial.
And it does, when it's weighed up
against a great political cause,
you say, well, how could you deradicalize someone
from believing in, you know, literal race genocide
by getting a partner, getting a romantic partner.
But the need that is driving it
is ultimately rarely political.
And it is usually personal and that sense of connection.
Someone finding a church,
or finding another sense of community.
I mean the thing that I did to kind of unplug myself
from social media and to, you know,
I don't think I was radicalized,
but we're all micro-radicalized by social media.
The thing that I did to de-micro-radicalize myself
was just find group chats,
and just set up a like Slack of friend groups
that I've used to replace social media
and just spend more time with people in person,
which it sounds so pat,
it sounds like they couldn't possibly be the answer,
but I think it really is.
Yeah, so you changed your media--
Exactly.
Diet habits.
Right.
So what changes did you make?
So the answer that you usually will hear people say,
I was just listening to an interview with someone
who was talking about this.
And she was saying, well, spend some time on social media
and then spend some time reading traditional news outlets
and try to determine which one
is giving you better information.
And that made me laugh because we know the answer,
and also that's not how people work.
You know, that's not why people are spending more time
on social media.
I think the replacement that I made
and that I would really encourage people to make
is to identify the thing that social media is giving
that you're finding addictive is the feeling of validation,
the feeling of connection,
the feeling of having a community who support,
maybe you're getting or not getting,
but you are definitely chasing.
And if you can replace that with,
you know, a group of runners,
or a group that you go cycling with,
or what I did, and just had a big like group chat
that I check in with 30 times a day
instead of checking Facebook and Twitter 30 times a day,
it will supplant the need that is driving you
to the social platforms.
And I think that will take care
of a lot of the downstream effects
of how it's changing your politics,
how it's changing our emotional balance.
Yeah, so there's that piece, that feeling of connection
and the external validation
that comes with social media use,
but sort of related, but separate
is the issue of validating your information feed, right?
Sure.
There's misinformation, there's disinformation,
there's propaganda, there's traditional news sources,
and more and more, people are consuming their news online.
They're not going offline
to actually get a physical newspaper,
or less and less are they watching cable news.
It's more about like what shows up in their feed, right?
And these new, you know, quote unquote, news sources,
some of some legit and some of ill repute,
it's becoming more and more,
you have to become a lot more savvy and sophisticated
to discern the difference
between what is vetted and legitimate
versus something that is not, right?
And I don't see that problem getting any easier to solve.
I mean, I think, you know, especially young users
are more sophisticated in certain ways of under,
you know, they're more internet literate,
but I don't, I see this problem becoming more problematic,
especially as technology advances,
and, you know, we're gonna see deep fakes,
and all this other kind of, it's gonna get super crazy
compared to what it it's gonna feel quaint right now
compared to where it's headed.
And I don't see a lot of discussion
about how we're gonna manage that,
or what we're doing right now to kind of vet news sources.
Right, so this is, I think,
one of my most kind of categorical takes on social media
and how to deal with it is that you are, I think,
full stop, not going to be accurately informed
on social media.
And it's not just, are you following the right accounts?
Are you, you know, careful about which news sources you read
because you could do that,
but the ways that things are framed on social media
is still going to be consistently misleading.
And it's more fundamental than that too.
The way that you consume information
completely flips and changes when it's in a social context
than when you're just reading an article.
There's this really fascinating study
that I write about in the book,
where a bunch of researchers
got some Republicans, Conservative voters,
and they showed them a, what was it?
It was a fake headline about Central American refugees
showing up at the border.
It said something outrageous,
like all the refugees are actually criminals with ISIS,
something clearly false.
And if they would ask people,
even very serious committed Republicans,
whether or not they considered the headline to be true,
just the headline, do you think it's true?
The overall majority would say, no, that's not true.
And then they would ask them,
do you wanna share that on Facebook?
And they would say, no, I don't wanna share it on Facebook
because it's not true.
But if they showed another set
of Republicans Conservatives the same headline,
but they dressed it up as a Facebook post,
and if the first question they asked was,
do you wanna share that on Facebook?
The overwhelming majority would say yes.
And then if they asked, is that true?
They would say, yes, that's true
because I just shared it on Facebook.
So when we are in a social context,
we're not judging for accuracy.
We might think we are, we might be trying to,
we might have set up the right outlets to follow,
but it's not where we're looking for.
We're looking for is identity, we're looking for validation,
we're looking for things that we think
other people in our community wanna see.
So I think my advice for individuals,
which doesn't solve the problem systemically, I know,
is just don't read headlines or news in a social context.
Just don't do it.
Good luck with that.
I know, you know?
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome,
but I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know actually
already know how to eat better,
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is The Plant Power Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches seven days a week,
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people, for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
It's not just the post that you see on Facebook,
it's who shared the post, right?
Right, how they shared it.
Who is that person?
Do you identify with them?
And then this terrain that you get into in the book
about what are they called, super sharers?
Super posters.
Super posters, right?
Who have like this air of legitimacy,
like oh, I wanna align with that person,
I believe like they're credible in other areas.
So if they're sharing this,
I don't need to read the article,
I can read the headline and because I feel aligned with them
or I wanna be aligned with that person,
I will just reflexively reshare it.
Right.
Can I tell you about the school bullying thing
that kind of led me to that?
'Cause this unlocked so much for me,
and I feel like helped me really understand
how social media can change your sense of morality
and right and wrong.
So I was working on a story
that was related to this research
that areas with higher Facebook usage
saw more racist attacks on refugees basically.
And I was trying to figure out, is that, could that be true?
And could social media actually change
your sense of right and wrong,
which is something that I think a lot of us suspected,
but how can you actually demonstrate that?
And I went to this woman named Betsy Levy Pollock,
who's a researcher, I think at Princeton,
and she's got a genius grant, and she's a very smart lady.
And I said, how would you try to go about figuring this out?
And she had worked a lot in like Rwanda and Genicera,
which I thought she would wanna talk to me about,
but she said actually, the biggest comparable case here
is school bullying.
This really interesting study that she did,
where she went to a bunch of high schools,
and she had this theory
that people determined whether or not they think bullying
is okay to do, not based on any internal moral compass,
or not based on what their teachers tell them,
but by what they think their peers collectively believe.
But they can't, you can't put out a poll if you're a kid,
to know what do all of your peers believe?
So she said that she thinks
the shorthand people were using was,
trying to spot the few people in their community
who seem to be the most influential
and the most visible, judge what they think about bullying,
and then they would mirror their internal beliefs,
their sense of morality, right and wrong off of that.
And she tested this by identifying the like 20 kids
out of like every 1,000,
a really small number who seemed to be the most visible
and who had been,
I guess you would say supportive of bullying.
Maybe they were bullying people on Instagram, online,
and got them to just stand up and say to their community,
in some context, I actually think bullying is wrong,
and I don't think that you should do it.
And just doing this,
just having the influential kind of norm setters
in the community change what they were conveying out
to the rest of the community,
completely flipped everyone in the school.
And not only was there much less bullying after that,
but the surveys that she would take of the students
found that they internally had come to think
that bullying was wrong.
So this is this idea of social reference
that we derive our norms from a few influential people
that we used to infer the whole community.
And on social media, the way that those social reference
get picked out is the platforms designate
a few people who they believe
their systems believe are going to be very engaging to us.
These are super posters,
and it puts those people in front of us over and over again.
I bet if you opened up your Twitter feed,
the algorithm would show a few people on the top
over and over again.
100%, yeah.
'Cause those are the people who you engage with, right?
I mean, same thing happens on my feed.
And it's a few people who the system is just learned,
I look at their tweets a little bit longer,
maybe I'm like to like it or reply to it,
these are people who I pay attention to.
And it's going to surface posts from those people
and those individuals who deliver the type of content
that is most engaging, which means the most outraged,
which means the most kind of us versus them,
the most tribal.
And these are also people who have been studied a little bit
in the last two years,
and kind of their psychological temperament.
And it's a little concerning.
They're basically bullies themselves.
They have a few tendencies.
Grandiose narcissism is one of them,
which is associated with insecurity.
And that's why these people use social media a lot
because they really need the validation.
Something called negative social potency,
which means someone who derives pleasure
from seeing other people in pain.
This is also something that plays really well
in social media,
because if you're someone who goes on and yells at like,
hey, look at this idiot, look at what this person said,
that's something that will drive a lot of engagement.
So these are the people who offline, are not influential.
And I went and interviewed a few of these people
who were elevated by the platforms,
and they're not basement dwellers,
they're just like regular people
who happen to be really hiked or active,
and a little bit mean on social media,
but they set the norms for these entire communities.
Yeah, and that's something that is true
on the right and the left.
Absolutely.
Like if you're looking at the political sphere,
there is similar like strategy or tactics that are at play,
like they're Shot and Freud at like,
oh, pointing out like the misstep of the out,
you know, the party that they're making fun of, et cetera.
Sometimes it's mean spirited, sometimes it's comedy.
It's, you know, just a ferocity of volume,
you know, like it's lots of posts, right?
And it's interesting what,
no matter what silo you go into,
it's those are the people that rise to the top
and that the algorithm is gonna elevate.
And they do, they set the tone.
Like, oh, this is what's acceptable in this discourse
to be part of this in group,
and to signal your membership in good standing
by resharing it or doing your version of that post.
Right, and these are people who, in the offline world,
if they're especially noisy or kind of obnoxious,
would be maybe shunned,
or maybe would not be that influential.
But it is behavior that serves the algorithms
rather than the social norm,
so it's what gets elevated.
And it's something that happens,
not just in political spheres,
but one of the big cases that I talk about in the book
is this happening in basically mom blog groups,
and where this leads over time,
where you have these forums of young parents
who are sharing information,
and this was like gamers,
one of the first really big communities to migrate online
because you have a lot of gen X moms who are,
you know, trying to figure out this parenting thing,
it seems hard.
That the people who would rise in that community
were the people who were conspiratorial,
who had the kind of sharpest criticism of doctors,
or of government policy around childcare,
and where this ultimately ended up leading over time
was towards anti-vaxxers,
which grew out of these mom Facebook groups,
mom YouTube channels,
because it was the end point
of all of that kind of negative social potency,
and this tilt towards conspiracy, conspiracism and extremism
that would get promoted on the pages.
Right, and Renée DiResta
being kind of the tip of the spear
and rooting that out, and helping to,
you know, people to really understand how that transpired.
Yeah, I was very happy to talk to her a lot in the book.
And she is someone else who started as a real true believer.
I mean, she was an investor in Silicon Valley.
She was going to the conferences.
She was involved with some of these companies.
And she started to see this kind of interesting parallel.
On the one hand she was online,
and she would see what the hell is going on?
These Facebook groups,
all of a sudden have crazy anti-vaccine sentiment
that is a complete minority offline,
but is totally dominant online,
which she later figured out was because
it just performed so well.
And at the same time, she's in Silicon Valley
and she's going to these investment conferences,
and she's saying, well, why do these companies
that have no revenue model,
that have no way to bring in any money,
but just say, oh, I'm gonna get a billion users
and then sell ads against it,
why are they getting all of the investment money?
So it was funny to talk to her,
to see these kind of two things converging in once
and where it ended up playing.
Right, and of course, similarly,
this gets played out in all kinds of other issues.
You talk about the, you know,
the anti-immigration situation is Germany or Austria.
Germany, yeah.
Yeah, where, you know,
there's this sense if you're online,
that there is a tremendous amount of acrimony,
you know, towards these communities of people
that doesn't really represent accurately
the true sentiment of the greater population,
but ultimately ends up driving a lot of,
you know, really bad behavior.
Yeah, it was wild going to these towns,
and this is a story I did for the Times at the time,
and it's a chapter in the book
where everything in the town would seem great.
Like people were really friendly towards,
there would be big refugee populations,
'cause this is like 2015, 2016
when a lot of refugees had just come
from Syria, Iraq, and Afghanistan.
So there's a lot of resettlement happening in small towns.
And if you went into the city streets,
people were really nice to them,
they would be helping them to get groceries.
You would go to these community centers
that were really well funded.
But then if you would go online,
or talk to people who would go online,
it was just completely flipped.
And it was just this racist, hatred, and vitriol.
And I thought what was so striking about that
is it was a reminder of,
despite what Mark Zuckerberg might say,
the platforms are not actually neutral shows
of what is already in the community,
or maybe it picks out something that is there,
but it's kind of small, and it's on the fringes,
and it blasts it out and widens it out
because online social norms that say refugees are great
and we accept them is not going to win that much engagement.
But something that says,
you have something to fear in your community,
these new neighbors are really scary,
and you should be really upset about them,
it's going to surface every time.
Sure, and that's not just opinion,
because it was being fueled by fake news stories about,
you know, rapes, and crimes and all that kind of stuff
that actually wasn't factually correct.
Right, yes, it was a lot of misinformation
that would go viral because it would kind of hook in
to the sense of fear and the sense of identity threat.
And it would lead to violence.
There were a few cases that I talk about in the book
of people who were fine,
and then would start spending a lot of time online.
Maybe weren't even political,
and would start to drift towards these ideas
because they felt online, like it's the norm,
and it's accepted and this is how everybody feels.
And they're doing, they're serving the greater good
because they're solving this problem on behalf of everybody
which goes to that group identity piece.
And you know, suddenly having a purpose,
you know, some meaning in your life to redress,
what they legitimately feel to be a harm.
Right, it's actualizing.
It gives you an identity, something to hold onto.
And if you talk to people who kind of fall down that,
they're often legitimately surprised
that their real, actual real life community
is not gonna greet them as champions and heroes
for what they're doing.
And when you become so invested in that,
it becomes very difficult to disabuse people of it,
no matter what facts you put in front of them.
Like you see this with QAnon,
there's still people holding onto this idea, right?
Right, with QAnon, it's sad because it's,
I mean, for a lot of reasons obviously,
but a lot of them really are just lonely.
Well, that was the big piece there
was the community piece.
And the gamification of all of it that made it
this mass group, you know, activity
where they could get together
and try to solve these puzzles.
Right, right.
It gives you a purpose,
it helps you make sense of the world.
And it helps you understand
if something bad had happened to you,
maybe you'd lost your home, you been displaced,
you're alienated from a family member.
It's all part of this larger struggle
where you can find all of these other people
to help you with it.
But it started with, this is like the one,
I tried not to hold back any reporting for the book,
but there was one thing that I just didn't get a chance
to put into an article that I put into the book,
which is that the origins of QAnon
is of course it's the Pizzagate conspiracy theory,
which is, and again, it sounds so crazy
when you say it out loud,
it's the idea that Democratic elites
are harvesting the blood and the organs of children,
sounds so stupid.
Adrenochrome.
Adrenochrome, right, yeah exactly.
And that was something that had,
that rumor had actually spread spontaneously
in about a half dozen different countries
before it ever came to the United States as Pizzagate.
And I had like, just coincidentally,
I was reporting on social media extremism in Indonesia,
which is this giant Southeast Asian country
where social media is a very powerful force.
And this rumor that was like identical to Pizzagate
had spread there before it came to the US.
It had started out on this like very obscure account
where someone just, I'm sure,
just made up this rumor that like,
oh, the elites are coming to steal our kids
and our baby's bloods and organs, excuse me.
And the Facebook algorithm just identified it
as something that was going to be tenaciously powerful
and started spreading it, went viral in the platform,
so other people picked it up and started sharing it.
And within a couple of weeks of this,
seven different villages in different parts of the country,
all rose up in spontaneous mob violence
and lynched some guy
who just happened to be traveling through.
Whoa.
All at the same time.
Which I had never heard of anything like that
happening before.
And there's no link or shared DNA
with the Pizzagate origin story?
This just happened completely independently?
That is kind of what's crazy about,
is it's this, it popped up there, it popped up in Mexico,
popped up in Guatemala.
I think it was a similar version in Nigeria.
So there's something about this specific conspiracy
that just--
Locks into people.
Locks into people, yeah.
And these algorithms which are really smart,
and because they have the largest datasets in human history
of what will tap into our minds and impulses and what won't,
it had just figured out that this is something
that is gonna spread, and spread at one time after another,
until it became QAnon.
Well there was also a gamification of the Pizzagate thing
because it involved this dump of emails, right,
that then ended up on 4chan,
and all these 4chan sleuths are going through them,
and, you know, kind of coming up with coded messages,
you know, about what means what,
and anagrams and all that kind of stuff that led to this,
you know, grander theory that,
you know, gets played out
when that guy actually shows up at Comet Ping Pong,
what's it called, Comet Ping Pong Pizza.
With his AR-15, and what went down, went down,
you know, he bursts into the,
what he thinks is gonna be the door to the basement
to discover that it's a closet after all.
What has always blows my mind
about the way that story ends is he shoots into the closet,
which he thinks is the Pizzagate, you know,
child harvesting dungeon, turns out it's computer room.
And so he just puts down his gun and surrenders, that's it.
He just, he knows that it has led nowhere,
but the conspiracy is still out there and still spreading,
even though he has kind of realized
that there's nothing actually to it.
Right.
And the platforms, of course, could not care less.
So, all right, so we have a sense of the problem, right?
In your reporting on this and all the work,
and that you've done,
and the people that you've spoken to,
what is the thing that is, that most shocked you,
or surprised you about the extent of this problem?
I think it was honestly learning that using the platforms,
it was what we talked about, using the platforms,
influences your own sense of right and wrong,
even when you're not on them.
And it was this sense that it's not just the Pizzagate guy,
it's not just the QAnon people,
that it's all of us who are being distorted by it.
And when I started to learn about that,
I, you know, really scaled back my social media usage,
I turned off a lot of the features,
and I really felt the change.
I felt a change in my mood,
I felt a change in how I think about politics
and the news that happens.
If I don't read it through social media,
if I just read it through, you know,
regular, old websites or podcasts.
And I think that, maybe that just shook me the most
because it implicated me.
You know, probably objectively,
I should be most upset about the fact
that Facebook played a major role in a genocide
that expelled a huge population of Myanmar from the country.
But it's hard not to come out of this thinking,
that I was affected too without realizing it.
And that if that is true for billions of people,
including like 80% of Americans,
then the effect must be pretty profound.
Yeah, this mass unprecedented experiment
that is being performed on all of us in real time.
Right.
Without precedent.
I mean, it almost it's,
I'm gonna sound like that guy from Dr. Strangelove.
It's almost this like pulp B sci-fi movie
where they're putting drugs in the water,
and nobody realizes it
and we're all taking it without realizing it.
I mean, that's more true than not.
Right.
You know?
So when we try to understand
what the possible solution to this is,
it very quickly becomes incredibly complex and tricky.
And it seems to my mind that this battle
is being fought on several fronts.
On the one hand, we have this argument
about free speech, right?
That's right, yeah.
Free speech being a core fundamental premise
of all of these platforms that you track all the way back
to the inception of Silicon Valley
and the sensibility of these founders and these engineers.
So we have the free speech piece.
We have this piece about how
everything can be solved through engineering,
which brings up the algorithm.
We just need a better algorithm to solve this.
And then the third piece to my mind
is the reluctance of the people
who are running these companies
to at least publicly acknowledge the problem
or the extent of the problem,
and to get into action in terms of solving it.
Right.
It's tough, it's really tough
when you think about the corporate incentives,
because at some point you're,
it's like asking cigarette companies.
They're antithetical to each other, yeah.
Right, right.
And it just, the way that our system and our economy works
is you're asking these giant companies,
or we're asking these giant companies
to disavow the thing that makes the money
to say that not only are cigarettes addictive,
but you shouldn't smoke them or, you know,
not only is pumping oil bad for the environment,
but in fact, we should probably,
you know, radically downgrade the amount of energy
that we use.
This is a question of, I think it's more helpful
to think about where you want to end up,
and then try to figure out how you get there
than the other way around.
Because when you try to, when you start with,
how do we get there,
it's easy to say what we'll just tweak the algorithm.
That was the solution after the 2016 election
is they said, well, we'll get better engineers to come in
and have even more sophisticated algorithms,
which of course just made the problem fundamentally worse.
When I would ask people who study this,
including a lot of people who are still in Silicon Valley
and are true believers,
what's the place that we should try to aim for to end up,
it would always be some version of turn it off.
Not turn off the entire thing,
'cause social media does provide a lot of good
that we don't wanna give up,
but turn off the engagement maximizing features,
turn off algorithms, turn off the,
even Jack Dorsey, the former head of Twitter,
he for a while was saying
maybe having a little light counter at the bottom of a tweet
is incredibly destructive to our society in politics
and maybe we should turn that off.
In the later, I mean he was kind of late to come around,
but in the final stages of his tenure
and the twilight of his reign,
he had some real epiphanies that ultimately
were not made real, right?
Right, and there was a period
where he was pushing against the financial incentives
of his own company,
and all the other companies
were growing by leaps and bounds and his wasn't
because he was kind of constraining its growth
because he thought that it wasn't healthy.
There is a version of social media,
that like any platform of any kind
can have some negative effects to it.
But the pre 2008, 2006 pre-newsfeed, pre-likes social media,
it didn't have a lot of these harms.
And it was something that contained a lot of the good
that we hope for, and like, and appreciate
from social media,
without these distorting effects,
and without this kind of addictiveness
and the changes to our behavior
because they didn't have engagement maximizing features.
So it's perfectly possible to have that.
Then it just becomes a question of
how do you actually bring that about?
Yeah, I mean, on the incentives piece, to my mind,
the genie's out of the bottle,
and the incentives are driven by engagement,
and the purpose of the engagement is ad revenue, right?
So it's an ad supported model.
And this is predominantly the reason
that these platforms are built
the way that they are built, right?
So one solution
without eradicating capitalism altogether, right,
which is, you know, if we have a revolution
and we become, you know, our government gets overthrown,
that would change things of course.
But assuming that that's not happening,
well, who knows, I mean, maybe we are on,
maybe be the civil war revolution, I don't know.
Maybe two episodes of abolished capitalism too.
Right, but one thing that could accomplish this
would be to sidestep the ad model
and go to a subscription model.
Like if Twitter became subscription only,
and everybody had to pay two bucks, or nine bucks,
or whatever it is,
that would have a revolutionary impact on it.
I mean, Sam Harris had said that,
you know, Jack Dorsey would've won the Nobel Peace Prize
if, when he stepped,
he just turned it off the switch, right?
Like that's probably not gonna happen,
but I'm not the first to suggest
that a subscription model would be,
would create a healthier ecosystem.
Yeah, I think that's right.
And I myself have switched from in the media companies
that I've worked for,
from one that was primarily advertised and driven,
to one that was subscription driven.
And it's not the same scale,
and also there is, you know, a lot of human input on media,
the way that there's not with social media,
but I felt the difference in incentives, sure.
When you're just trying to say,
I wanna provide a product
that people will find meaningful enough
to hit subscribe every month,
rather than how can I hook as many people
for as long as possible.
Right, and it doesn't mean that you have to eradicate
the algorithm because when you look at,
like look at Netflix.
Netflix is totally algorithm driven,
but I don't feel like I'm being, you know, manipulated.
Like I feel like when I watch certain things,
then that algorithm does a pretty good job
of showing me what I might like to watch next.
And the reason for that algorithm
is to drive up my engagement.
Like obviously they want to keep me on Netflix
for as long as possible, but it doesn't have the same pull.
Like I feel like I'm being, maybe I'm being manipulated,
and I don't know, I'm sure I am, right?
But it doesn't feel pernicious in the way
that the other platforms do,
because it is a subscription model,
and it's not trying to, you know, I don't feel like it's,
I don't know what I'm trying to say.
Like, is it trying to radicalize me and I don't know?
You know, like I don't know,
but it just, it feels a little bit more benign.
No, I agree.
Being on Facebook.
I mean I think that it's a difference in,
if they were really just trying to maximize your watch time,
they would be showing you soft core porn,
and car wrecks all the time,
'cause that's the thing that would keep you watching
for long periods of time.
But they're not, they're trying to show you the Gray Man,
which is also not great, but for different reasons.
Oh, that's that Ryan Gosling movie
that was terrible, right?
Yeah.
I was, I had such high hopes for him.
We'll come back.
Yeah, that was bad.
Yeah, he's got another dame inches out movie will be okay.
But and Spotify is the same way
where they ultimately what they want
is for you to be happy with the experience.
And it's a very powerful, very sophisticated algorithm
that is trying to make you happy
with having a subscription to Spotify,
which they can achieve things
other than trying to make you addicted
and listen to many, many hours of content.
Let's talk about the free speech piece then.
So with this, I mean, obviously this is the debate
that's raging across all of these platforms.
Like what are the parameters of free speech?
How much free speech should be allowed?
And with the maturation of these platforms,
we've seen a grappling with this issue in real time,
and some legitimate movement from free speech absolutism,
to recognizing that that's not gonna work.
Look at 4chan, look at 8chan, see what happens
when you completely shirk any responsibility
for managing that,
to a real conundrum around what we should accept,
what we shouldn't, and the differences between the platforms
and how that's managed.
Right.
So you alluded to this, but the free speech absolutism
has this kind of founding ideal in Silicon Valley,
that if you completely remove the gatekeepers,
you completely remove the rules,
which you should do,
because ideas should be completely free,
then the best ideas will naturally surface.
And this is actually something
that comes very specifically out of engineering,
where it's just, whoever makes the best widget,
they should be in charge of making the widget,
which makes perfect sense
when you're making a semiconductor,
but it has never worked that way
because what it always favors is,
first of all, raw majoritarianism,
which we have learned can be a very destructive force,
especially on these early social platforms
like 4chan and Reddit,
but also that the best idea
is not going to be the most engaging idea.
So this is why we've seen over and over
that pure free speech leads to very intense
and extreme version of majoritarianism.
There's still a question--
Sorry to interrupt, but like just a thought.
If that premise was true,
then in the Reddit ecosystem, for example,
where you're upvoting the best comments,
that it would follow that the most insightful,
most intelligent comment would always be the most upvoted.
Right.
We know that's not the case.
Yeah, I defy you too.
And what's ironic is that Reddit
has actually gotten much better,
and the quality of the discussions and the content on there
has improved drastically because they imposed gatekeepers.
And because they have people
who work very hard at moderating the conversations,
which is what we do in the real world,
is we have a sense of norms that we enforce
formally and informally to try to encourage
what we think is gonna be a constructive conversation.
So even Reddit, your free speech has come around to this.
But the story that you tell around the CEO,
what was her name, Powell.
Ellen Powell.
Powell, yeah.
Like her story was pretty illustrative
as being kind of at the forefront of that debate
and how she got, she kind of got churned out.
Yeah, she was someone who, earlier than most of us,
certainly earlier than I did,
saw where that raw majoritarianism was going.
And she saw it partly because she's a woman of color
in an industry that, at that point,
especially and still is overwhelmingly white and male.
She also saw it because she had been an investor
at Kleiner Perkins, this huge tech investment firm,
and had had this discrimination lawsuit against them
that had made her more thoughtful
about the ways that the Valley is not welcoming to people
who are outside of the Valley's majority.
And she did try, sometimes haltingly, sometimes very bravely
to change the way fundamentally
that the platform and the technology worked
to privilege healthy conversation
over lots and lots of engagement.
Like we talked about super posters.
She actually identified the super posters on Reddit
who were posting, yeah, toxic.
Got rid of 'em.
Yeah, she got rid of 'em,
it was like, I forget the number, it was very small.
It was like a couple thousand users out of millions.
And it was this incredible change
where there was a study that had some academics conducted
and they found that the amount of hate speech
overall on the site dropped substantially.
It like 80%, I think.
Was it 80%?
Something like that.
It was a crazy statistic.
It was a really high number,
which just goes to show the power that these platforms have
to tilt an entire community one way or another,
even if we don't.
But she got excoriated for it, and ultimately fired.
She did.
She was lambasted as destroying free speech.
She was a big target of the movement that at that point
was kind of burgeoning Gamergate,
was harassed pretty severely,
and in ways that were very sexist and racist
on the platform.
And for that and other reasons,
was quickly pushed out of Reddit.
So that was an early experiment
that kind of went sideways, right?
But you know, kind of a canary in the coal mine, right?
So here we are,
and we still have the Zuckerbergs out in front saying,
listen, we're not in the business of policing speech.
We may find this speech to be deplorable,
but you know, we're not,
these platforms are not about moderating that,
or quality control on speech.
And yet they've been forced to reckon with this
because of the violence that we've seen play out,
which puts us in this really weird murky place
where moderation being an imperfect science,
whether it's human driven or AI driven,
is going to have, you know, scattershot results
that are gonna ultimately make nobody happy.
Everybody's mad, right?
I'm being shadow banned, I'm being downvoted.
I post, nobody sees it.
It's a conspiracy of the left
to suppress Conservative voices, vice versa.
All of this we're seeing, you know, being discussed,
you know, ad nauseum online.
Nobody seems to have a good grasp
on how to truly solve the problem.
Meanwhile, we're kind of spinning out of control
without any real solution in our sights.
Right, and the where you draw the parameters of speech,
acceptable speech, unacceptable speech,
is in some ways an unsolvable problem,
and it's one that we have been continuously litigating
in this society, in every society,
for as long as we've had social norms in a society.
It's also, I think in some ways,
it's a little bit of a, it's a red herring
that the Silicon Valley companies
actually really like to draw attention to
because it's sympathetic, and because when you isolate it,
so like, well, should this be allowed
or should this be allowed?
Or is this post okay, is that post okay?
The problem is not which posts are allowed and not allowed.
And this is something Renée DiResta has really emphasized.
It's what gets promoted, and it's what gets amplified.
And if you had platforms
that did not so reliably and consistently
amplify the things that were so harmful and so distorting,
the free speech question just becomes a lot lower stakes.
The potential damage of making the wrong decision
one way or another becomes a lot less dangerous,
because if you leave something up,
if you leave up a piece of hate speech
that's getting engagement from three people,
then it's not good for those three people who saw it,
but it's ultimately not gonna be--
You may be crying fire in a theater,
but there's nobody in the theater to hear you.
That's a great way to put it actually, I like that.
It's such an interesting thing, like this idea of,
of the obligations of the platform.
I mean free speech has to do
with government regulation of speech, not--
In social regulation.
Yeah, social regulation defined how?
So if I were to use a racial slur on your podcast,
which I'm not gonna do.
That's not illegal, but I would face,
and you would probably face social consequences for that.
Oh sure.
Okay, I understand what you mean.
Right, and then so that's this idea of social sanction,
the way that we informally police one another's behavior
and social norms in ways that are not necessarily illegal.
You know, someone cuts you in line for the bus,
and you kind of tut tut them,
that social sanctions are someone,
one of your friends has joins a political group
that you think is damaging for society.
And you say, well, I'm not gonna be your friend,
or I'm gonna distance myself from you
to punish you for that, that's social sanction.
So it's this form of informal regulation
that we all participate in,
and it it's messy and it's imperfect,
and it gets stuff wrong.
But because it's something that we evolved in
over millions of years, we're reasonably good at it.
And that is something that you see on platforms
that don't have these distorting algorithms,
that don't have these engagement maximizing features,
is they don't naturally reset
to a naturally healthy discourse,
but you know, like this kind of more recent Reddit
after they've done a lot of work on this,
if you can think thoughtfully
about how you have responsible gatekeepers on the platform,
how you can have your social reference, your super posters,
be people who are setting positive norms
instead of negative norms,
then the question of what do the moderators have to remove,
that also becomes a lot lower stakes
because it's the community
that is doing a lot of the enforcement in terms of,
if someone says something terrible on a platform
that's not Facebook that is more legitimately neutral,
then the other people on the platform will say,
well, you know, you shouldn't say that
because that's a hateful thing to say.
Right, right.
I mean that a related matter to that
is the impact that socialization of speech
can have on somebody who transgresses it, right?
So this is the Justine Sacco example of,
so you've been publicly shamed.
Like the people who misstep,
sometimes with intent, sometimes without intent,
who then suffer a disproportionate amount of,
you know, alienation and out group dissonance,
you know, or even outward hate as a result.
And this is something that is created by a social dynamic.
It's not driven by the guideposts
of the platforms themselves,
but ultimately is having
a real pernicious effect culturally,
and I think a chilling effect on, you know,
people feeling like they should even say anything,
like what is, why should I?
Like if I'm gonna suffer this kind of consequence,
who wants to go through that?
Like, I mean, nobody does.
It's terrible.
And that deep sense of being cast out of the tribe
is a very primal, painful thing
that you talk about in the book.
Like physically painful.
You experience it as physical pain.
Right, because we evolved in an environment
where you literally cannot survive
without the approval and support of your community.
It's, you know, tribes of like 100, 150 people
that we evolved in where this was something that was,
you really needed to maintain.
And if you lost it, if you upset the rest of your tribe,
it could often be fatal.
So that is why when we,
if you're online and you're getting yelled at by 200 people,
it feels really, really bad
because your brain has evolved to experiencing that
as a mortal threat, akin to, you know,
being stabbed with a spear, akin to losing access to food.
But because of the way that social media works,
if you do something transgressive on it,
you know, if you do something transgressive in real life,
maybe eight people who see it will say,
you shouldn't do that and will kind of modulate their voice
based on what they think is appropriate
based on your transgression.
If you do it online, it might be 2,000 people,
or might be 20,000 people who get really mad at you.
Probably not 20,000, but it'll be a really large number.
Or you're caught on video,
and then it goes viral, and millions of people.
Right, yeah right.
Which it's sometimes it's a real transgression,
and sometimes it is not a real transgression
because these things move so quickly on social media.
And the incentives for each individual user
are to participate,
because participating in a pile-on on someone,
it feels really good.
It is physically pleasurable to do,
and it is something that you feel an urge to do
because you know it will win you
the approval of your community to see,
to say, you know, I'm one of the good ones too,
I share this sense of morality,
and I share this sense of moral outrage
against this transgressor.
And sometimes that can be productive.
I mean I talk about this Central Park incident
from summer 2020.
The bird watching guy and the dog walker.
Yeah the dog walker, this woman who she had,
I'm sure people remember it, she had her dog off,
there was a black guy was a bird watcher
who said please leash your dog,
and she called the police
and pretended to be in mortal danger,
which at that particular moment
was something that she knew
carried the threat of the police coming
and killing this guy basically to, for, you know,
this sin of asking her to leash her dog.
And that is something that pre-social media
would not have gotten punished,
and therefore is activity
that would have been allowed to perpetuate
that it's dangerous and bad.
And social media allowed for the social sanctioning of that
in a way that would not have been possible before
at a huge scale that sent a message, not just to this woman,
but to other people who might be seeing it
and who might be one day tempted to do something similar
that you shouldn't do this
because you will pay a social cost for it.
So that's good.
Right, weaponizing your privilege to sick the police
on somebody who actually didn't do you any harm or wrong.
Right, who doesn't deserve it.
What I didn't know about that,
I mean obviously I remember that when that happened.
What I didn't realize was that the gentleman who,
the bird watcher--
Christian Cooper.
They were both called Cooper, the woman and him, right?
He, he didn't even wanna make a thing about it.
It was his sister who shared the video.
Right, yeah she shared it,
and he, it was funny reading interviews with him
about it after the fact, where he would say,
you know, what she did, this woman, Amy Cooper, was bad,
and she was trying to unleash certain dark forces.
But he said, I don't know that her life
needed to be destroyed over this,
because the punishment that got meeded out
was just determined by the raw group dynamics
of the platforms where--
Well, it was also timing, because it happened to--
That's true, right.
Coincide with, you know,
the kind of outset of Black Lives Matter and all of that.
So it was a flash point.
It was like a perfect storm of events that met the criteria
for what people were interested in talking about.
Right, interested in talking about,
had legitimate real anger that they wanted to express.
It just happened at this scale where,
you know, she gave up her dog at one point,
the shelter that she had adopted it from.
It's unclear exactly how like recalled the dog from her,
to the point where even her victim was saying,
this seems like a little bit much,
was a striking example to me because I think,
I think we're all vaguely aware,
but it's tough to articulate sometimes
that even when this online social sanction
is towards something that is deserving,
and might be used towards that are helpful for society,
that it quickly, quickly can run out of control
because the scale and the incentives of the platform
just tilt towards these extremes.
And because it's something that happens a lot to people
who don't deserve it,
but they were caught in a photo or in a video in a way
that it looked like something bad was happening,
or they were maliciously portrayed
in a certain way as having--
Right, like the Sandy Hook parents.
Right.
In the Alex Jones example.
And then you tell the story of Cecil,
the Cecil the lion, which was another big one, right,
with the dentist who, you know,
I mean that was a whole quagmire shit show.
It was both, I would, yeah.
That would, to me felt like, I think looking back,
I think that was the tipping point.
I think that was the last, in my mind,
that was the last moment
when it felt like just the internet.
And that was, if people don't remember,
if you were online at the time, it was a really big thing.
I think it was early 2016, like 2015,
an American guy, a dentist from,
I think St. Louis was in Zimbabwe.
He was a big game hunter,
and he shot a lion under circumstances
that were in a illegal gray area,
but near a park where it is legal to shoot lions.
Right, the lion had been lured out of the perimeter
of the park where it was legal.
Exactly.
He was also a beloved lion who had a name,
and, you know, there were a lot of,
and listen, you know, a big game hunter
is the least sympathetic person you're gonna come across.
Yeah, right, right.
It's hard--
And why are they always dentists?
Why are dentists always the big game hunter guys?
Dentists are more, it's also the always the dentist
done at Mar-a-Lago.
I think this is the kind of the secret
like swing vote in American life.
Next time you're at your dentist, have a talk and say,
you know, are you doing okay?
Right.
So yeah, so this guy, this dentist shoots the lion,
this goes crazy viral on the internet.
He has to go into hiding basically.
Yes, he has to, as the kind of outrage cycles
grow and grow and grow first on Reddit, and then on Twitter,
and then on YouTube.
I think I've probably retweeted or reshared something
about that.
I think we all did.
Because it, I mean, it's when you're one.
It is outrageous, anyway.
Right, no I agree.
It is outrageous.
And when you're one individual,
what could be the harm of calling out something
that is outrageous and saying that that's what it is.
It's a kind of collective action problem,
because for any one individual person,
I mean except for the people
who took it to physical threats, I would argue,
it makes perfect sense
and is maybe even the moral thing to do.
But when it gets amplified through these platforms
and at this insane scale of millions of people,
it becomes distorting,
I think out of scale with what he actually deserved,
'cause he and his family have to flee their home,
his dentistry practice has to shut down,
which means that people he employ are out of work.
He was in hiding for weeks
because there were people who were spray painting his home,
there were people who were threatening to kill him.
It was this like national hysteria.
Like Jimmy Kimmel cried on air over the lion,
which it's not to say that it's not sad, but it felt to me,
and especially feels looking back,
like this moment when the moral outrage of the internet
and the moral outrage incentives to the internet,
because how many of these people really cared about
Cecil the lion before this happened?
Like zero, right?
Is something that can be so infectious,
and it can spread to this insane scale
that have these consequences,
that are first of all, beyond what anything is planning,
'cause there's no central arbiter saying, you know,
this dentist deserves this punishment, this punishment,
but not that punishment.
It's just happening through collective action.
But also because we're all complicit in it.
So no one wants to say
maybe we shouldn't threaten to kill this dentist,
which I think is partly why that incident
has been kind of forgotten.
I mean the New York Times ran like 10 articles about it.
Yeah, and for every story like Cecil, or the bird watcher,
there's a million other ones, right?
So here we have this problem.
This problem's not going away, the weaponization of speech,
the policing of speech, the mob unleashed, the doxxing.
You know, there's clear cases where we can all,
maybe not all of us, but like reasonable minds would say,
this is probably not good.
Too far.
We should, yeah.
But where do we draw that line?
And once you get into drawing those lines,
it becomes infinitely problematic.
So this is the problem that all of these founders
are grappling with.
This is the problem that we're grappling with,
this is society.
I don't see it getting any easier to solve.
Like where do you come down in terms of your thoughts
on the best way to manage and rectify
what is wildly spinning out of control?
I think that it's,
I think it starts with asking a slightly different question,
or kind of reframing the question in our minds.
The kind of the version of the question of, you know,
what's the amount of outrage that we allow,
or what are the posts that we allow or don't allow,
it's a little bit like thinking,
where do we put all of this toxic sludge
that's coming out of this factory, that's in our backyard?
Should we put it in drums, or should we put it in, you know,
plastic containers?
Or should we--
Go dump 'em in the bay?
Right, yeah, or go dump it in the bay.
And another way to think about it is,
should the factory be producing this much toxic sludge?
Is there a way that we can maybe just dial things back
in the factory so that it is not polluting our homes?
And I think that those questions get a lot easier to solve
when you think of it less in terms of
how do we manage the outputs of the system,
and more in terms of how do we get this system
to stop pumping out the sludge?
And that's partly a high level regulatory question,
which there's more movement on than you might think.
There's a real chance that some of these platforms
might get kicked out of big parts of the EU.
And that's something that could really happen.
Wow.
What gives you that sense?
The regulators there have imposed
some pretty strict fines.
The social attitudes towards the platform
are a little bit different, especially in Germany,
which is a big deciding vote in a lot of EU matters.
There is really a sense that this is like this foreign thing
that has come into our country is polluting it.
So it feels easier to kind of say,
we should just get rid of it.
But I think if it does happen,
the way it would happen would be imposing rules
that are impossible for the platforms to follow
without fundamentally changing their nature.
And you've already started to see the start of this,
where you see German laws that Facebook is legally culpable
for certain kinds of speech
if they don't preemptively remove it,
which is not possible under their current model
where the posts go out and they review it after the fact.
And then I think the choice will be
this kind of game of chicken, where the EU will say,
well, you can stay,
but you have to completely re-engineer your platforms
to meet the standards that we set.
And then these companies will say, well, you know,
Europe is a shrinking market for us anyway, which is true,
because adoption rates are going down,
and population rates in Europe
are pretty static or declining.
And our future is in the developing world,
so we'll you see later.
Right.
But that would also set up
a sort of Cold War domino thing, right?
Like if Europe falls, what's next?
They've set a precedent.
You know, my mind goes towards what happens
when every country sets up
different laws and regulations and rules
around how these entities can operate in their territory,
which becomes impossible,
because these are global entities, right,
so how are they gonna, you know,
sort of partition how they're managing it
based upon, you know, geographical boundaries.
Right, and the companies have started to get
pretty aggressive about fighting back.
Do you remember this thing in Australia?
I think it was about a year ago,
the Australian government was setting these new rules.
Oh God, what was it?
Oh, it was Facebook had to,
Facebook and Google both had to sign agreements
with major Australian media companies
to basically say, we Facebook, or we Google,
will give you a portion of ad revenue
because we are selling ads against your content.
Right.
Which was, there are differing views
on whether or not that was a good law.
It was promoted very heavily by News Corp,
which is a major media presence there.
But Facebook's response, Google said, okay, we'll do it.
And they cut deals with media companies
to pay them a bunch of money
for the rights to host their content.
Facebook said, okay, we won't host any news.
And they just flipped the switch,
which blew my mind for a couple of reasons.
And one was that I remember very clearly,
three years before that,
in the middle of the genocide in Myanmar,
when the United Nations is screaming their heads off
to say Facebook, you were driving actively
this ongoing genocide,
and Facebook refused to turn off the platform,
and were getting asked by journalists,
just please, would you consider switching it off?
And they said, no, we won't do it.
But when someone targeted their ad revenue in Australia,
all of a sudden it's lights off,
and it had a real impact on the country
because these platforms have been so successful
at dominating how people consume news and get information.
All of these like domestic abuse groups
that were based on Facebook,
like weather groups couldn't get information out.
And there are other websites
that people could obviously access to get the news,
but of course, once news publishers
were blocked in Australia,
what filled in the void for people on there
who wanted to learn what was going on in the world,
but rumor and misinformation.
Sure.
And so it was a, I think a telling blow that there are,
or a telling incident that there are gonna be
more fights like this
between governments and the major companies,
which we don't experience here as much
because it's like unthinkable.
How could we shut down our own, you know,
three or four largest companies in the country?
But in other countries, it's much more live question.
It was interesting how Facebook got its hold
in some of these developing countries, right,
where you describe the, you know,
distribution of low cost mobile devices that were pre,
you know, pre-programmed with a rudimentary Facebook app
already built into them,
and deals that Facebook struck with cell providers
to basically give them free data plans for a period of time.
And so that basically, you know, created a situation
where their only way of communicating with each other,
and for purposes of how they're sourcing
their information and news was through Facebook.
Right, which they presented at the time
as this great gift to the world,
that we're going to go out
and pay for cell phone internet data.
Just like the drug dealer giving you the freebie.
Exactly, right.
And if you look at the way
that they would talk about it internally,
it was all about owning the market.
It's all about, and this is what they did in Myanmar.
So people have cell phones for the first time,
people have internet for the first time.
We are going to make sure that they 100% access the internet
through Facebook.
So that when this market matures
and becomes worth something--
They're already so inured to it.
Right, and they're completely addicted, and we control it,
and what that, one of the many things that means
is that local publishers, like let's say a newspaper,
a media company can't possibly compete, because it's free.
How can you compete with free,
and how can you compete with also it's on your phone
and it's so shiny?
And they, the displacement that happened
was just devastating to a lot of reporters,
a lot of media companies,
a lot of publishers in these countries.
And if you talk to people in these countries,
they think that Facebook is the internet,
that little F button and what it pulls up,
they think that's what the internet is.
So there is really not as much of a standard or practice of,
well, you have your Facebook,
but you also go load up the Myanmar Times website,
or you also go load up these other eight ways.
You load up your Gmail account to go email with people,
it's all through these one or two companies
that control all the information and discussion,
which is kind of nuts.
It's really about what sacrifices we're willing to make
for the sake of convenience, right?
So when those phones come preloaded with Facebook,
you can probably go out and get other apps.
You can, you're free to do what you want with that,
but when it's so convenient,
that's gonna create habit formation around that.
So, and this is playing out for all of us,
like I had an experience just the other day,
I went for the first time into an Amazon Fresh.
Have you had this experience?
I've been into them once, yeah.
You have, so I mean, for people that don't know,
like, okay, pull out your Amazon app on your phone
and hit the in-store locator thing, it pulls up a QR code.
And you walk into the place and you scan the QR code,
and then you just go and put whatever you want in the bag,
and then you leave.
And there's, and then you look up at the,
there's a scaffolding just like we have up here
in the studio, and there's so many cameras
that are looking at you.
There is nothing, I mean, if you, you know, pulled a note,
a hair out of your nose, it would notice it, right?
Like, and I had this strange sense of like,
I am being so hyperwatched right now.
And you consented to it, you chose that.
I chose it.
This is the point that I'm trying to make.
So I went in, I was like, I wanna see what this is like,
I went in and then I did it.
And it is weird to like, okay, I can leave now?
Like, I think there's that Saturday Night Live skit
where Keenan, what's his name?
Keenan Thompson, yeah, he's like there and it's like,
he thinks he's gonna get arrested 'cause he's black.
He's like, no, you can leave.
Like, I was like, am I, what is happening, right?
And I thought that is incredible,
it's so unbelievably convenient,
but am I comfortable with that?
Like, I don't know, and I keep thinking about it,
like this is something that that is at the,
that's like right at that friction point
of like convenience and the sacrifice of privacy.
Of course, Amazon is collecting the information
about what I've bought,
and is then gonna use that data to serve up
whatever it's gonna serve up to me.
Sell you more things.
Yeah, you're all a pawn in this greater thing, right?
And that is when I have heard,
I'm generally skeptical of arguments
that breaking up the companies will improve things,
because it does nothing to change
the underlying business model of maximizing engagement
to sell ads.
But one of the versions of the argument
for breaking up the companies that I have heard
that does make, I think some logical sense
is that their enormous market power,
just the billions and billions of dollars they have,
and the fact that they control
all of these different aspects
of how we relate to the outside world
and engage with the world around us,
makes it very easy for them
to introduce something like this, to say,
well now there's a store everywhere,
and it's in every community, and there's all these cameras,
and you normally would never say yes to it,
but we're gonna make it so easy,
and maybe we're gonna give you a little bit of a discount
for going there,
so eventually you're going to acclimate to it.
And that is something,
I mean, it's like Facebook going into Myanmar for free,
and saying we're gonna lose money for 20 years
so that we can own it for the next 100.
It is interesting.
I mean, it seems like such an easy lift to say
that WhatsApp and Instagram
should be divorced from Facebook, right?
And to me, the fact that the Justice Department, or the FTC,
or the Antitrust Department or the Justice Department,
can't make that case or has not yet made that case.
Like it feels feckless on my part,
you know, from my perspective
that they haven't proceeded in the antitrust actions
that they have gone, that they have pursued
seem like weak versions of what the real problem is.
You mean in terms of changing
the underlying mechanics of this.
Yeah, right, yeah, yeah.
There is this sense where it's,
it's a blunt instrument for what they're trying to do.
It's a hammer when maybe you need a scalpel.
Some of the cases, I know I'm not a lawyer.
It's tough for me to say how compelling they are or not.
You would know that better than I would.
Some of them do, at least people tell me
that they are proceeding
and that they might be a little bit more promising
than we think.
There's some argument that they work as a deterrent,
that it's just, you better stay on our good side,
or else we're gonna bring down this enforcement action but--
Right, but meanwhile.
I mean, come on, look at how they continue
with wild abandoned to build and grow and consolidate.
Right, it did look around like 2017
like they were really gonna try
to make peace with Washington.
And I actually, as I say that, they really did,
and they were actually enormously successful
even as Trump and a lot of senior Republicans
were railing constantly against
the sort of social media companies
had cultivating a lot of people in power in Washington.
But what they were not prepared for
was the flip to a Democratic administration.
Although it's tough for me to say,
there's a lot of talk
out of this White House and Justice Department,
that now that we're in power, we're gonna use our 48 years
to do the thing that they manage,
these companies managed to buy a reprieve from in 2016
when they kind of got Trump on their side.
I don't know if it's actually gonna happen or not,
I honestly couldn't say.
It doesn't feel like it.
If it is gonna happen, it's happening quietly,
which may mean it's not happening.
Yeah.
So as we kind of start to round this out,
where do you, if things continue on this trajectory,
the way that they've been playing out,
like, what is the, you know, where is this headed?
Like can you paint the picture
of the near and distant future?
So I got, it's hard to say
partly because the platforms change a lot.
So we don't have a great sense of TikTok's influence
on politics and society.
Well, that's a whole other podcast,
especially with Chinese ownership, et cetera,
and the black box nature of it all.
Right, it's so black box, and the Dynat,
what it surfaces and doesn't is so different
from other platforms,
that we don't have a great sense
for what the implications of that are
for users individually or collectively.
And there could always be another platform
that has some entirely different effect.
But I will say that I spent a lot of time for this book
in Brazil,
which is a country that is very similar to the United States
in so many ways in terms of it's politics,
it's social divisions, it's racial divisions,
it's economic makeup,
and felt to me like it is a few years ahead
of the United States in terms of social media's influence,
which is just as big there as it is here.
And I profiled several people
who were YouTube influencers basically,
who were now in high positions of government.
Bolsonaro, the president, he kind of got a start
as like a YouTube guy.
He was just like this fringe person
with very little constituency in the country,
but a huge influence on YouTube.
And I think the hints of the future that I got from Brazil
are that I think the relationship
between politics and social media is going to flip.
And I think that we are going to see less of social media
as a place where some political influence plays out,
and then feeds into politics,
some kind of the bottom up in the way that we saw in 2016.
And I think that we are going to see more politics
driven actively by and mirroring social media,
in the way that in Brazil,
you don't have lawmakers who are trying to appease Facebook.
You have people from Facebook who are now in government,
and the constituencies that they're serving
are the social media algorithms,
because that's what put them in power in the first place.
That's interesting.
It's hard to imagine that here though right now.
You think so?
I don't know.
I don't think we're that far from it.
I don't think that we're far from,
I mean, in some ways with the like stop the steel candidates
and the Republican party who are rising up,
and some of the QAnon people,
like these are already people who came from social media
into politics.
Right, right, right.
And I think that that is something that is,
we're gonna see more capture that in the Republican party.
I don't know exactly what it would look like
in the Democratic party, I just can't say,
but it would not shock me if we saw a version of that
soon enough.
And what is that forebode from your perspective?
I mean when you think about the incentives
of political leaders, what are they trying to do?
They're trying to get reelected, right?
Or they're trying to go from the minority party
to the majority party.
And those incentives have been changing in American politics
for a long time because of the collapse and weakening
of the party system,
because of the way that politics
are increasingly nationalized,
where you look at your lawmaker
as a representative of the president's party now,
instead of as someone who you might have
a more personal local relationship with.
But I think we could be facing a much larger flip
where it's not just that politics are nationalized.
If you're running for a house seat in Congress,
you're thinking of, how do I fit into
the national political conversation,
but you're thinking,
how do I fit into this social media conversation?
And that means how do I get the right number of people
on Facebook or Twitter or YouTube
who are gonna be into what I'm doing?
And that's just, it's a different market.
It's a different constituency,
and it's a different set of interests and incentives
than you have in traditional retail politics.
Sure.
You have to understand the vicissitudes of the algorithm
and play that game, to literally game it in your favor,
which means it's gonna push both sides towards
the more radical fringes
of the respective parties and view,
and that's gonna then push the constituents
in that direction as well,
until we're so far apart
that it doesn't feel like the nation can cohere.
I mean, this is the dystopian, you know,,
end point of this whole thing.
And it's like insane to even contemplate
that that could be a reality,
but it does feel more and more prescient.
Yeah, I mean, I think it's,
if that is going to be slowed down,
that's a change that I think can't just come from
whatever we do with these technology companies.
That is something where it's also a symptom of,
like you were talking about,
one of the symptoms of extremism
is people feeling left behind in society.
This is also a symptom
of our political systems' gatekeepers really weakening.
And speaking of whole other podcast,
like strengthening the party system
and strengthening political gatekeepers
is definitely a whole other podcast,
but that feels to me like the only way
to kind of slow or even start to reverse this trend.
Yeah, do you feel like the gatekeepers on Capitol Hill
are becoming more educated and savvy
about the perniciousness and ills of social media?
I mean, we've had, famously there was these hearings,
but you know, sort of aside from that,
there was this sense,
like these guys don't actually really know what's going on.
So I remember the hearings were some of the questions
were like, what's a Facebook page?
How do I post?
Sir, we sell ads.
There's that whole thing.
There has actually been,
especially in the last like two years,
and especially after January 6th,
I think a, a really impressive education on--
That's encouraging.
It really is.
And even the member of the house
who represents Silicon Valley,
which I was kind of blown away by, have really come around
to a much more sophisticated understanding
of what the roots of the problems are,
and what pressure points on the company to point to.
I did a story about YouTube's algorithm,
plucking out home movies of little kids
in various states of undressed
that looked innocent on their own,
but then stringing them together in a way
that was meant to sexualize them,
and to present them as soft core pornography basically.
And after that came out,
there were letters from a couple of senators
that I was kind of blown away by how on point they were,
where they were demanding Google and YouTube
change where in the product design process,
safety and social impact people would be involved,
which is something that you,
I wouldn't have even known to ask about,
but I ran that by someone and they were like,
wow, this is like, they talked to someone
maybe probably who left YouTube or left Google.
But I think they're starting to see
that they need to understand how the companies work
and how the companies make decisions,
and then find little pressure points like this
that they can try to bring attention to,
to try to steer them in better directions.
And how receptive are the powers that be
at the YouTubes, Facebooks, and Googles to zero, right?
0%.
Who's the worst?
It depends on how you measure it,
but the answer is YouTube.
Maybe just everybody who I have talked to,
if I would ask, which is the one that is most pernicious
in its social impact,
and which is the company that is most hostile
towards social pressures and towards political pressures?
No matter who I asked, their answer was always YouTube.
Sorry.
Yeah, that's just, it's unfortunate, it's unfortunate.
It doesn't mean that, of course that everything,
I mean, I watch YouTube.
Doesn't mean everything on it is bad,
and it doesn't mean everybody who works there is bad.
But just the way that the company happens to be structured,
the way that its systems happen to work,
their destructiveness,
maybe because their destructiveness is less apparent
and has gotten less attention than Facebook.
That's the argument some people make
is that they've been allowed to skate a little bit
and the way that other platforms haven't.
They're segregated out,
and they're this kind of like money maker
for Meta and for Google,
whereas Facebook is, you know, the main market thing.
It's like the ATM for Google, right, in many ways.
Yeah.
What's interesting is as somebody who's on YouTube
and you know, we're filming this
for YouTube right now, right?
It's a constant conversation that we have here
about how we position our content on YouTube.
And of course, I know that if we come up
with a crazy clickbait title
and some wacky, you know, thumbnail,
we'll get more views and I just refuse to do it.
And yet, and so we suffer the consequences.
Like we don't get, you know, the views that I think
that our content deserves by and large,
because we're opting out of playing that game.
But I need to sleep at night too, right?
And so, well, maybe we can,
so it's a constant thing.
Like, can we say that?
Like is that okay with you or is that, you know?
And it's like, it's not even a conversation I wanna have,
like I just wanna put, you know,
episode number, blah, blah, blah, Max Fisher.
And what's tough is that you can wrestle with
and torture yourself and make the right choice,
and someone else is gonna make the wrong one,
because anybody can put anything on YouTube.
Someone will go the 10 extra steps be more extreme,
be more provocative,
and the algorithm will find them, even if it's, you know,
someone who is using a $7,
$7, $70 camera and microphone.
Yeah, but I still, call me naive, Max--
Naive.
But I still believe that-
Yeah, you're calling me naive
before I've even shared my thought,
that over the, if you play the long game over the long haul,
like ultimately, you know, water rises to its own level.
How do you mean?
Meaning that if I, like, from my perspective,
if I keep just trying to put out the best conversations
that I can, in the nuanced form that they,
you know, often are,
that ultimately it will find its audience.
Sure, yeah that's true, yeah.
But it won't happen quickly.
It definitely won't happen as quickly.
There's no short cutting to that,
and there's a trust and a faith that comes with that
that exists outside of any algorithm.
Right, and I mean,
you are still finding an audience on YouTube,
that's partly to the algorithm.
I mean, it's still helping you.
And it occasionally, you know, like we'll hit a,
we've, you know, we've had a couple ones
that have hit the algorithm lottery and go crazy,
and then of course you try to reverse engineer it.
You're like, I don't know why that happened.
Right, yeah.
I talked to some political activists who used YouTube,
and they were, in their view, trying to use it for good,
but they wanted to say,
well, we need to reach a lot of people
because we are trying to, this is in Brazil,
we're trying to change politics in a healthier direction.
And one of them was telling me that after like six months,
they looked up and realized
that they had endorsed all these views
that they had hated beforehand,
because it was just so easy to follow those incentives.
But you can, I mean, the thing is,
none of these platforms are all bad,
and promotion is not inherently bad
so you can still have a really good podcast that reaches,
you know, a really great audience on YouTube.
And does it, in terms of the promotion on YouTube,
basically for free, which is pretty cool.
Yeah, 100%.
I mean, I think that it means
that you have to shoulder responsibility for how you use it,
and understanding that you are,
that the deck is stacked against you,
because it's so powerful and addictive.
But to the extent that you can manage to restrict yourself
or to, you know, come up with rules that work for you,
it can be a positive.
My whole career is based on the internet.
It's on YouTube, and Instagram, and all these places.
And as a result of Twitter and Instagram,
I've been able to connect with
an unbelievable number of extraordinary people
that have enriched my life.
So it isn't a black or white thing, but I think it is,
you know, it is just more important than ever
for people to realize how powerful it is.
And as your book so beautifully illustrates,
it is changing our behavior, whether we like it or not,
or how resistant we are to that idea,
because it's an assault on our agency, and sentience,
and all of that, this is happening.
And so please, you know, reevaluate your relationship
with these platforms.
And maybe you can kind of end this.
You already alluded to how you've made
some behavioral modifications, but leave us with, you know,
some poignant thoughts on just how powerful it is,
and maybe some other ways in which we can modulate
or think about our information diet,
and the extent to which these platforms are useful or not.
I think that you hit the nail on the head.
I think that's the dilemma that you described
is the dilemma, a microcosm.
It's like food addiction, you still have to eat, right?
So nobody's gonna be, we're not asking you to be a Luddite,
I'm not gonna be a Luddite.
No, I don't, you know, I sometimes will hear people say,
throw away your smartphone.
You can't throw away your smartphone.
You can be like Johann and go to Fire Island for a summer,
but you know, ultimately he's back on the phone.
We live in a world that is dominated by these platforms,
and maybe one day that will change.
But as an individual living in that world,
we have to make peace with these systems
that we are gonna have to use
to understand the world around us, to relate to people.
And we're all facing a microcosm of the same dilemma
that you described, which is how to be moral on them,
knowing that the platforms make it more appealing,
and enticing, and rewarding than it's ever been to do things
that we would otherwise consider immoral.
And they make it harder and harder
and more of a disincentive to try to be responsible
with even just individual words that we might use
on dashing off a tweet,
because each of these things that might feel like
you're just at a stop light and you have a few seconds,
and you're just gonna dash off a comment,
but they all play into this broader system.
They're all training the algorithm,
they're all training yourself, they're training your peers,
other users.
And the, maybe the best thing that you can do,
I mean, you should try to modulate your usage,
you should try to be really thoughtful about
how often do I really have to be on it?
I post like 5% as much as I used to.
But probably the best thing you can do
is just to be really aware about
when you go to tweet something, or post something,
or to record something on YouTube, being thoughtful about,
is this because I think this is a good idea
and what I wanna do,
or is it because this giant corporation
has nudged me towards doing that
because they wanna make a little bit more money off of me
and try to addict other users
to make more money off of them?
And what do I want my input into this giant system
that is shaping everything in the entire world to be?
And conversely, applying that same rubric
to your consumption,
like do I really need to watch this video,
or click on this link or whatever?
Like I think just being much more mindful
and responsive versus reactive.
And there are little tricks you can do.
You can set up times where your phone
will shut off certain apps.
You can turn your phone onto grayscale,
which is actually incredibly helpful
in making it less addictive.
It doesn't take away too much from it.
But ultimately I think it's just about knowing,
and it's just about trying to find that will
to decide what the right thing is gonna be,
and then to do it,
even if it might feel really good
to look at some more tweets.
It's tough, man.
My eldest stepson, he is 27 now.
Him and his brother are among the most analog people
that I know, which speaks to, you know, that generation,
has a different, it's interesting.
Like some young people are more analog
than a lot of people that are my peers, right?
So he went and got the Light Phone,
you know, the Light Phone?
No.
So it's a cell phone that comes
with just a rudimentary stack of apps.
Like you can listen to podcasts on it.
Oh, that's cool.
But it's a black and white like LCD screen.
Oh I think I have seen this.
And you can do text,
but they make it all very hard, right?
Like, and it's a tiny little thing
and he's like, this is what I'm doing now.
Like forget the iPhone.
And he lasted a couple months,
but it just became impossible for him to be in the world
and communicate effectively with people like,
and he ultimately ended up going back
because this is how powerful these things are.
We're tethered to these things.
I bet that you know exactly where your phone is right now.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, I bet everybody, I know where my phone is.
They've done these studies.
It is an appendage.
It might as well be embedded inside my brain.
You know what is a really fascinating thing to do?
Sit down with someone.
If they have their phone out,
and take their phone off the table and watch them,
it's like you took their arm off.
Just watch how they react
to seeing their phone taken away from them.
Because it does feel like an extension of ourselves,
which is not something that we acknowledge to ourselves
because it's not fun to admit that.
But if you become aware of it,
I think it makes it a little easier
to be kind of thoughtful.
Like okay, that phone is not actually me.
It's not actually my community.
It's not my social network.
It's not my friends and family.
It's just this little beeping device
that has some cool stuff on it occasionally.
And oh so rudimentary in the singularity
to which we're headed, right?
We'll look back,
can you believe they carried these things around?
And it's amazing, when you put it that way,
it's amazing how vast and rapid the changes have been
given that smartphones,
the kind of modern smartphones that we have now are so,
are they're so new.
So new.
That was crazy about going to Myanmar.
It's hard to remember pre-iPhone,
and yet it was kind of yesterday.
It was kind of yesterday.
And there, you can go to countries where,
like Myanmar I went to right before they opened up
to the outside world and there were no smartphones,
you couldn't get a SIM card.
And then I went three years later,
and everybody had a smartphone and it's the same people,
but the way that they think, the way that they relate,
the way that they talk,
it completely changed over three years, due largely in part,
and this is something
that people there would tell you and told me,
just little piece of technology
that had dropped into their hands.
Yeah, so the iPhone was that 2006, 2007 when that debuted?
That sounds right, I got mine in '08.
Yeah.
So, but it was still a number of years
before the app economy was really up on its feet.
So it wasn't necessarily the iPhone per se,
because that was just a Blackberry with a touch screen,
until the App Store really kicked into gear
and all these third party apps
started to become mobile first.
Right.
So that wasn't really until,
that didn't really kick in until--
2010.
Yeah, 2010, right?
So we're talking about 12 years.
And everything is completely changed.
Completely changed.
Yeah, I don't know what it's gonna be like in another 20,
or we'll all be farmers in 20 years.
Yeah, is it gonna be Mad Max Fisher,
or are we gonna go back to some kind of
agrarian bucolic society?
Well we're gonna find out.
I don't know.
You're the, so there, you're the truth teller here.
I don't know, maybe.
That's the next one.
Well, we'll have you back to, you know, explain that.
Like I said, at the outset,
this is a really important book, The Chaos Machine.
As of the recording of this, it hasn't come out yet,
I'm sure it's gonna be huge.
You got a beautiful, amazing review
in the New York Times today.
Saw that.
It just came out.
I knew it was coming out this morning,
I did not sleep at all.
I was so nervous, but I was happy.
I was very relieved.
No, it was very good, it was very good.
And this is gonna put you right in the center
of this important conversation
that so many of us are having.
And like I said, it is, you know, if not the most important,
one of the most important conversations
that we need to be having.
This affects all of us.
And this book really does an incredible job
of not only unearthing truths,
but really taking the reader
through the most comprehensive kind of traverse
of all the issues that come into play here.
So, you know, well done.
It's a, I mean I can't imagine the amount of work
that went into putting this book together, it's incredible.
You've written a book, so.
Yeah, but not a book like this, you know,
this is a different thing.
This took you all over the world and hundreds of interviews
with all kinds of people.
And you know, it's a book about foreign diploma,
international diplomacy, it's about technology,
it's about history, sociology, psychology, neuroscience,
like everything comes into play here.
Well I'm excited to see it out in the world,
and thank you for shining a spotlight on it,
and thank you for having me.
Yeah, absolutely man.
It's a pleasure talking to you.
So if people want to connect with you,
do you want 'em to connect with you on social media?
Listen, I'm as addicted as everyone else.
Well you got coming out, so I'm sure you're online now
in a way that probably you're not generally.
Oh yeah, I'm already thinking through
how much outrage can I get into my book promotion tweets
to get the most engagement.
Right.
Are you AB testing?
I've got a room full of monkeys typing the tweets
to see what's going--
In Russia.
That's right.
Yeah, Vladimir Putin is helping me out, yeah.
Excellent, excellent.
Okay, so if people wanna connect with you,
where do you wanna send them?
Twitter, Max_Fisher is probably the best place.
Or if you wanna email me max.fisher@nytimes.com.
Right, and they can read your writing
in the New York Times.
nytimes.com.
Yeah cool.
All right, man.
Thanks man.
Yeah, thank you.
Peace.
(calming music)